[Applause]
[Music]
well that was fast i was
kind of expecting we had a whole that
kevin smith club ad
i guess that'll come at the middle of
the show won't it jc
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith
i am mark bernardin hey oh
uh boy i couldn't wait to get to this
ladies and gentlemen
uh because falcon and the winter soldier
was so good there's so much to talk
about this week
um and so much to tell you
so much going on um i
wound up in the news cycle this week so
there's that as well
and then there's whatever the [ __ ]
mark's been up to how are you doing mark
uh i'm doing good man i'm doing good
it's been a it's been a week
of um recovering from the four-hour
ed brubacher podcast let me tell you
something i
[ __ ] he's crazy not to have his own
podcast and i'm not saying he's got to
be
you know uh howard beal the mad prophet
of the airwaves where every week he's
got to burn down the bridges
but like number one he's just
interesting to talk to
or listen to rather uh number two
like he's not afraid you know to talk
about unvarnished subjects obviously
but he gave he gives good content if he
had his own podcast he'd do quite well
he's a good he's a good storyteller and
and yet at your point like
he had some stuff to say and he said it
and he didn't really sugarcoat it he
didn't
go hard at anybody like none of it
seemed mean
or like acts grindy because he seems
like a happy dude it's like hey man i
got a great life
um but here's some stuff that just sort
of bothers me and irks me and then just
seems unfair
um so i'm curious to know if if anything
will
come of that on the other side if not
for ed then you know going forward for
other
comic book creators who find themselves
in in business of hollywood
and uh and then aren't being treated as
fairly as they could be
hey jc pop bam finn here if you will
something that i meant to talk about in
pre um
somebody watched a video that i did with
ice cube that's here on on the channel
on the youtube channel
and um for that since i was recording it
you know
as a podcast as well i jacked into my
sound
system and used like my microphone
as opposed to what i normally do for fat
man beyond is simply use the audio
mic that's built into my laptop then
somebody on twitter was like you piece
of [ __ ]
like you got that kind of tech and you
don't [ __ ] do it every week for fat
man beyond
so if i plug into this
will you indeed be getting somehow
better sound
we would have to hook the laptop
into your kind of like under desk system
there
but we can keys we could do it yeah we
could figure it out
what i'm saying is i can do it right now
let's can we do like a live test to see
if it improves sound one iota
yeah but you'll have to change it we can
plug it in
and then you'll have to change it in
zoom also
that's the next step but i bet you i
could do that all right well let's
folks if you bear with us i know we
should be doing this sort of thing
backstage but
if it improves the show why not
look behind the stage see a little
behind the scenes
it ain't always some creator going like
marvel owes me money man
like sometimes it's backstage you know
here
sometimes it's the geek squad um just
doing some some quick
um home entertainment system repair you
watch a bunch of old men go like where
does it go
all right why don't we put the coax
here's me to plug in
i'm going to wear these headphones the
whole time because i think it's a little
much with my
actually that does look cool all right
i'm jacking in
here we go all right is that better
sound
i think you're still if you go into the
zoom on the bottom
left see if you can change the mic to
like
input or something
external headphones select a speaker
audio settings would it be audio it
would be like select a microphone
test speaker and microphone no
it does all the way up at the top when
if there's options for microphones
it would have like macbook pro
microphone which is probably your
default
and then another one and if there's any
speaker but it does give not give me
microphone so computers are zoom's not
recognizing it yet
i can swing by at some point and we can
mess with it
um so but long story short that
the person on twitter who said [ __ ]
don't know [ __ ] is that what we're
getting at
uh i mean maybe we we can see if we can
get it to work
roush if roush is coming by he could
probably set it up for you too
okay so now this is me back to the sp
speaker in the
computer you hear any difference
whatsoever not really no
i think the only difference is is you
had the headphones in
so your audio from the macbook speakers
was going into the headphones so it's a
maybe one percent clearer thing was i
had the headphones in
i took the headphones out i put the
headphones in and then we shake it all
the time
and that's what it's all about
yeah when was the last time you went to
a wedding kid
it was someone's first seven-year-olds
um let me tell you something you want to
hear the sound of satisfaction my
friends
go for it you hear that you don't need
no fancy ass
microphone to pick up that sound what
does that sound sound
sound like sound of pleasure the sound
of a close
shave ladies and gentlemen oh
close manscape shave ladies and
gentlemen
uh that brings us to this week's sponsor
kids you know
how much we love manscaped manscape
must love us because they keep coming on
uh to be the proud sponsor
of fat man beyond as they are this week
man uh get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
fatman20 manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
fatman20
manscape.manscaped.com your balls
well thank you kids mark tell them
what's going on with manscape
you know what like not only will your
balls thank you if you take care of them
with manscaped
you need to take care of your balls
themselves did you know that one guy
every hour every day
is diagnosed with testicular cancer so
this is a reminder to all of the men
listening to check yourself
before you wreck yourself manscaped in
addition to providing the right tools
and solutions for safe and easy
manscaping has partnered with the
testicular cancer society
to spread awareness for men's health and
early cancer detection
together tcs and landscape are committed
to raising awareness for the most common
form of cancer in men
aged 15 to 35 and giving support for
fighters survivors and families impacted
by testicular cancer
as part of their we save balls
initiative
so while you're down there cleaning up
your sack why not go ahead and give them
a little investigation
for lumps and changes in size or any
pain
i think we can all agree it's pretty fun
playing with your balls
anyway manscape recommends you check
yourself once a month so if you do feel
any lumps or swelling
give your doctors a call manscaped kids
uh doing the lord's work there as you've
heard of course
but uh also just uh
doing the lord's work in terms of uh
looking out for your nuts
whoever in the history of
products uh has ever been like you know
what
i'm i'm sticking my flag on a set of
nuts
they need to be shorn like a sheep they
need to be
shiny and they need to be toned and
smell good and stuff like that i'll tell
you who created that somebody who's like
balls suck let's make them better and
they have man good folks at manscaped
has but have been making it better for a
long long time now
did you know that everyone the world
over
uses manscaped because it's now
available in the usa where we are
ready for the usa canada which is so
nearby to us
the uk which is like
[ __ ] harry potter's away from us
australia new zealand which are like
[ __ ] peter
jackson's the [ __ ] away from us and
stuff this manscape's taking over
the world kids you know why one simple
reason
balls everywhere yep like half the
people have balls
kind of i think that's the way the
numbers check out that's right
that's why only some people succeed
because only half people have balls
i'm mixing my metaphors good folks at
manscaped man we thank them
for being today's sponsor and fat man
beyond one more time get
20 percent off plus free shipping
with the code fatman20 at
manscaped.com that's 20 off 20
off to shave your nuts what are you
waiting for plus free shipping
with the code fatman20 at manscaped.com
your balls they're going to thank you
kids all right will wilkins jumped in
to try to talk me through this he's i
plugged back into the board
he says click zoom us
in the left hand corner preferences
and then choose audio which is there
next to the test mic button you choose
your digital interface from the drop
down so here's the test mic button
that says speaker so obviously not that
um external headphones maybe
hello you guys still there yeah i can
still hear you
and then no there's only one microphone
and it's the macbook air microphone
so no will wilkins you sent me two notes
as if you're like come on kev a child
could do this
and now i look like a [ __ ] dick twice
[Music]
we're back to reality can you hear me
yeah never never stop being able to hear
you you're all good
uh that's what happens when you try to
improve perfection kids you get too
close to the sun
on wings of wax look at all that cool
summer gear
bring it in here man we can show it off
my kids tv show cruel summer debuts uh
this week
4 20. thank you like you didn't
you didn't know 4 20. momma you're in
the other room there [ __ ]
kardashian lady um
so they just sent over a bunch of
branded swag stuff that says cruel
summer all over it
cool summer 420 on freeform you can see
it on freeform that's right kids um
there's so much to talk about my friends
later on in the show
christian harloth going to join us to
talk about the showdown
which both me and mark mark and i have
both been on
indeed and christian will try and get me
to come back yeah may or may not
i may or may not uh uh bow to his
desires we'll see
hemp mark back into the league man
gun shy because he took some licks last
time
i got hit hard but jeez you can't you're
too good at this
so they're gonna try to drag him into
league so we'll talk to christian about
the shmo down um but before we do that
of course we'll talk about
uh falcon and the winter soldier do our
recap
um that'll be first order of business
after
uh we talk about uh whatever [ __ ]
we've been working on
uh this week kids i was uh in the news
because we announced that we're going to
open jay and sal and bob's crypto studio
ooh
graphic that's going to fly in right
about now jay and sam bob says yeah look
at that [ __ ]
um it is uh our nft
um fun house mark and uh it caught a lot
of attention this week because
we announced that we're gonna sell uh my
horror anthology kilroy
was here as an nft the first movie to be
done
such although there's some debate as to
whether that's true or not but uh
um we are also selling these smoking
tokens
and with captain ridman art and the
black man and chronic cover that he did
as an nft
there's a sneak preview kilroy on ft
there's the platinum
uh smoking token gets you into clerks
three which we're shooting this summer
so it's all sorts of good stuff if
you're into the world of crypto or
or nft um some folks came at me pretty
hard on social media about like this is
not ecologically sound
however we are using the wonderful
phantasma chain
so um they're they are the most
ecologically sound
uh in the business they don't mine uh
for ethereum the way that other
companies do
so we we found a place that was pretty
pretty clean as far as this stuff goes
and um i don't know it's a blast we got
so many drops planned
uh but 4 21
is the first of those that's when we
open up the uh
jay and salam bob's crypto studio so
if you want to be in clerks three man
that platinum token is an easy way to
get into it
um and then if you wanna own a movie
and become a distributor there was some
uh you know consternation online when we
talked about selling kilroy as an nft
um i i guess some folks were like how is
that that hurts film i completely
disagree i
i talked about in an interview a bit of
motivation was 1997.
i was at south by southwest uh film
festival and we were doing a panel
and it was like bunch of directors and
there was quentin
robert rodriguez mike judge
um george huang who did swimming with
sharks
um steven soderbergh who
you know did everything and uh myself
and
you know everyone asking filmmaker
oriented questions quentin got a
question at one point somebody was like
how do i
be you or something like that and
quentin was like don't he's going this
business needs more
distributors and exhibitors like please
be that
it has so many filmmakers but like not
enough people to get the movies out
there and stuff like that
and so i always stuck with me i was like
ah that's true he's absolutely right
everyone wants to do this one thing
nobody wants to do the other thing uh
you win
the kilroy nft when we do it in the
second drop
you win the ability not only to
own this [ __ ] one-of-a-kind nft but
then in the real world you
get the movie like the hard drives all
the files same way as if we sold the
movie to a distributor
and you get to choose the movie's future
where it goes how to distribute it
where to take it and stuff its value
having been increased by the fact that
you
and complete outsider just bought it or
whatever
um so some people like what if the
person wins it and doesn't share it with
anybody
we're hopefully building in uh you know
this
thing that says like if you buy it you
gotta
just you can't just put it in your
wallet like you got it maybe
somehow i'm not saying you gotta take it
out to theaters and stuff
but i'm also gonna make myself available
like the same way i would if somebody
bought a movie i made to like dupress
and all that stuff go around promoting
the movie
so it's a fun way too for like somebody
who's in the world of crypto i certainly
don't recommend
this for somebody who's not deep in
crypto and rolling around
in uh in ether or whatever um but
like you know you for something you're
going to do anyway you could wind up
being a real world distributor as well
like you know it's an nft that has value
in the world of crypto but
it also has value in the real world as
well
so it'll be interesting it's caught a
lot of attention it's been
usa today like did a piece about it and
so
um i'll let you know when we're getting
ready for the second drop
what happens the first drop is this week
so next time we do a show i'll be able
to tell you like what happened
there and whatnot good old thing could
blow up and be unsuccessful but
i i've i've been i did a lot of crypto
press this week and it was very
very welcomed didn't feel people going
like what are you doing here people like
oh my god yes come and play and stuff
so um i look forward to it it's gonna be
fun this week the other thing that's fun
is on 420 itself the day before
um there's another drop and this is of
real world items clothes
man the hundreds is doing like a kevin
smith line of clothing that
looks like all the costumes of jay and
sam bob through the movies and stuff
it's really beautiful street wear
so the way they run their operation is
they only make a certain amount and then
they open the doors and there's a line
and
once it's gone it's gone so if you're
into that sort of thing if you want to
wear a hoodie
made up of all the blunt man and chronic
and chasing amy artwork and
baby dave all the fake comic books that
were in chasing amy they got that
they uh redid silent bob's long coat
jay's yellow coat um
brody's shirt uh j-shirt from dogma fork
and tongue like
really great stuff hockey jerseys hats
so if you're into that they haven't
shown any of it yet except
bobby's teased it on his instagram bobby
hundreds so if you're
in the street where and you're into
james bob street where
head over to the hundreds get ready
because 4 20 i don't know what time
probably early in the morning or
something
it drops and you can wear kevin smith
all the [ __ ] over you
um this was hell week for me and as much
as not hell meaning like it sucked but
i was just busy every [ __ ] day monday
and tuesday i was shooting
uh something that i can't talk about yet
but it's
masters of the universe oriented we're
getting very close
to
a um trying to [ __ ] facetime um
very close to more information coming
out next month uh people will see their
first
images to masters of the universe
uh revelation the the series that mark
and i worked on
um so we did something on monday and
tuesday it has something to do with that
literally just off camera i have the
toys the prototypes of the tour
i could be like the i could do the
ultimate show-off and you think we got a
lot of press
because ed brubaker spilled the tea oh
man
i bring you i get fired by mattel and
netflix and heartbeat
um so i did something in regards to
motu can't say what it was but we spent
two days working on it
gonna be wonderful uh on wednesday we
shot
uh a commercial with bobby hundreds we
went to the hundreds and
shot all the promotional stuff for the
drop this week
uh i got a physical on uh thursday
for something i can't talk about yet but
but one just for my health i'll tell you
that much i mean technically it was for
my health but it was also for
something else um and then i had a big
pitch
uh yesterday as well as doing like
crypto press all week
uh for the for the jane style bob crypto
studio opening so it was it was just a
packed
packed week and it was a nice rehearsal
for
we're about to jump into a busy period
you know we've been sitting around for
like the last year and stuff
and my idea of busy during the
quarantine
was never as busy as i was this week and
my life is about to get that busy again
every day for a couple weeks straight so
it was uh
it was it was a packed week man
yeah my week was not as packed but um
the thing that that i've been really
interested in
and kind of digging into like with death
water
used to be ice not anymore um
um we're in sort of like very early
pre-production on the short
that i'm doing on splinter and so this
past week was lots of sort of
interviewing
what will eventually be department heads
you know talking to
special effects houses talking to
directors of photography
um which is it's it's new for me in that
i've never
hired people like this before i've hired
people before um and i've worked with
folks like this before but i've never
been the guy
sort of making decisions as to who i
think will be the
the best person for the gig and it's
been really like eye-opening
and wonderful and just seeing the
different energies people bring to
things and the different levels of
experience
and how sometimes that is not the final
arbiter for
for the choice that you make you know a
lot of it is about
a different level what
that was weird um you know and and
and also starting to build out the
kickstarter campaign because
the plan is currently to launch the
kickstarter in middle of may
um to raise the moneys we need to
hopefully shoot by sort of fall winter
and so like learning about that now like
giving myself a bit of a crash course in
in sort of kickstarter not just
etiquette but best practices
and and ways to to quote-unquote game
the system
with things as simple as like when do
you launch it how long do you let it go
for
you know how many people can you rope in
to help you sort of beat the drum and
bang the gong to let people know that
now's the time
you've always been incredibly kind in
that regard so your budget what is it do
you know
i mean you haven't announced it or
anything like that we haven't announced
it yet but
you know the the the short you know and
i'm not being overly secretive about it
i can't be
given that the kickstarter will be
asking people for money for it but
um it's a limited cast but an expensive
location
and so i think that we're going to end
up
maybe being in the very very low six
figures probably between 100
to 120 000 we'll be looking for which is
a lot
um i'm totally aware of that it is not
the like hey it's three teenagers in a
car
or you know two adults you know having
marriage problems in a house
it's yeah you can't stick your story
behind the counter of a [ __ ]
convenience store my friend
i've heard that that's the path towards
glory working for some that's all
i i it's ambitious but you know it's
also
reachable i think you've got a large
enough fan base from the show
um you know i mean although like you
like to point out on social media that
some some cats are not fans or whatever
but i think
largely overwhelmingly so most people
are fans and would be very
like supportive man like uh so i feel
i feel like you'll you'll i feel like
you'll do well
like in a world where we had brubacher
on last week and he sent
us a lovely [ __ ] message about his
books [ __ ]
jumped up the charts i don't know what
charts he was looking at but
right and like overnight like this he
sent us a text like the next day
saying like i saw sales blips right
after we rapped
so you know like if that's
the kind of thing that our fan base or
the folks that watch the show who
i admittedly may not be fans like i hate
watch your [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever those that watch those who
support fat man beyond
which we don't really you know tax them
whenever like you gotta buy this [ __ ]
you gotta [ __ ] do this you know
i mean i guess we do ads and stuff but
like you know that's at their discretion
but
but in a world where we don't ask the
audience for a whole [ __ ] ton
i think going out there you know and and
being like
mark's gonna make a flick and [ __ ] i bet
you a lot of people will be like
yeah i mean it they'll do it they'll
they'll finance it just so they could
[ __ ] like
be negative about it when it's done just
to push it back in your face
i i will happily take hate donations if
that's
they're like you know the way you
treated the snyder cut
the bernard cut [ __ ]
go make your dreams so i could [ __ ] on
it
and i will thank you kindly thank you
for the said donation
um and welcome your harsh criticisms and
then my friend
you will know what it is to be a
filmmaker
that's awesome man so wait when you
you're talking about dropping at mid-may
when would you want to shoot
um the hope is to shoot in like late
october early november
um just to to a give
the the kickstarter some time we'll
probably have that up and running for 30
to 45 days
give enough time for real preview
production once we have the money in
hand and can start hiring production
designers and
sketches and storyboards and all that
stuff but also to let kovid kind of
recede a bit more
you know i think part of the budget you
know if we shot today
a third of the budget is spent in sort
of coveted safety which is
mandatory it has to happen are you uh
shooting uh
real world or are you uh is your plot
involved
elements like of the unreal
or um it's very real world there's a
little bit of vfx stuff
you know but it's not like robots or
dinosaurs or or
like character replacement or anything
like that right um
so movement is a factor like coconut is
100 effect even with it with a smallish
cast and even you know shooting
we're shooting all on sets so yeah
and so to be able to like let it kind of
fade away to let people get vaccinated
to let
you know all the tears begin to drop to
to and so hopefully we get a more
holistic filmmaking experience which i
kind of want for my first time like i'd
rather not be in a bubble
if i don't have to be if i have to be i
will be but if there's a way to let time
do its job
then um then i'm happy to let that do it
so yeah that's been a lot of this week
is working on that stuff um [ __ ]
exciting man look at you
taking a big old step you know i don't i
don't know
i don't know what happens on the other
side of it and i'm not even thinking
about it that much because you know like
my reps are like well do you want to be
a director now i'm like i don't know
i just want to do the thing and have the
thing done and then we'll see what
happens on the other side of it but for
those that haven't been
following closely mark had you know as a
kid was like i want to do a thing by the
time and when i say kid he was in his
like
you know whatever early 40s
like before i hit 50 was that it yep
before he hit 50 he said he wanted to
direct a thing and mark is going to be
50 in
like you know 10 minutes so he suddenly
realized
and the window is still open so that's
where this movie came from so you'll be
able to
support him when uh mid-may he drops the
kickstarter and whatnot
yes yeah and if you watch this show and
if you follow me anywhere
i will make it my my business to not let
you avoid it
because the only way to get this
unfunded will be to be a pain in the ass
about it
um but i'll try to be as nice a pain in
the ass about constantly banging this
drama as i can
you uh you know i i here
i think i figured out how we could raise
money for your kickstarter
when it begins okay do a whole episode
number one we can do a whole episode
where like you know what what do we
raise money for that one cause
oh yeah we did the the bookstores for
the independent mom and pop shops
so you we could do something like that
but
it's you re-reviewing the snyder cut
through an effusively positive lens
for all the people that were mad they're
just like that's worth the money
that's what i thought because i see how
much it hurts
i'm watching you slowly die
no this moment is amazing so much
character depth and plot acuity oh
i love it i love it um
will you do you require a bar in your
short
um i know a guy you know a guy who knows
a guy
i i don't require a bar for the short i
wish i did again if i was smarter i
would have written a thing set in a bar
no i wrote a thing set on a plane which
uh oh my god that's right
yeah so you need you need a set you need
a [ __ ]
i need a real deal set i don't need like
a like i can't sweep this
like in be kind rewind like i've got to
actually have a plane
deep cuts deep cuts
um however i think you know jc is kind
enough to volunteer the bar as the
location
for um my kickstarter video which i need
to record soon
oh yeah in which i make my plate in
which i
come clean and ask the big ask
give me some money please um
for those who are like hey man are you
drinking [ __ ] a 40 not at all this is
a
a well obviously not a 40 a uh uh tall
boy
um it's a liquid death it's that
drinking water it's just drinking water
but they got a [ __ ] real metal slogan
murder your thirst um somebody once sent
it to me
no they didn't how i found this [ __ ]
originally is i was
in a store like in another state and i
was like what the [ __ ]
and so when i came back home i was like
is it available and i found it on amazon
and then i instagrammed it one day and
then joe
in deathstroke joe uh was like
hey man like i'm involved with those
cats let me sell you some send you some
water so he sent me some more i think
he's on their board or something like
that
um but i now i just buy it so this ain't
even a commercial this is just
like water yeah i just like sometimes
it's easier than pouring water as i'll
grab usually i have it in the
fridge out there for guests but and i i
just get water out of our like you know
the water but we were running so late
and i was like oh [ __ ]
like i don't have time to pour water i'm
gonna grab one of these
and it's really now turned into a
[ __ ] free commercial which i feel
like kind of bad about but not bad about
because i actually like this [ __ ]
product but
for those who like what are you drinking
beer
i like to imagine the person who just
stumbled onto this show for the first
time
right now and it's like are they talking
about water
yeah man i just like to pour myself
water sometimes but if i'm in a rush
i just do the canned water why is this
show so popular is this what they
[ __ ] talk about like
what are they going to talk about falcon
winter soldier
what's that for all those who uh hey jc
how long have we been going what what
point of the show are we in right now
like the minute like 45 minutes
how bamf in here jc
35 minutes about
all right so this is for all you [ __ ]
who in the comments
when the video's done put up the exact
time that the the cat the falcon and the
winter soldiers
talk begins thereby skipping all that
awesome
what kind of water do you drink kev
chatter
that makes fat man beyond so very
jeff's [ __ ] kiss so if you're one of
those
[ __ ] little like time code terrorists
that has
everyone skip over to good [ __ ] just to
get to what you want to talk about
i say thank you
thank you come again uh let's get ready
kids now we were all for all
for everyone for what do they say when
you go to a place from
and now the moment you've all been
waiting for that's it yeah so long since
i've been in a [ __ ] public show
setting
i forgot the the terms of art mark it
was also like
what did they say when you go at a place
like i don't know what they
say i was awfully vague
i was like calling you on a lifeline for
that [ __ ] show
and only giving you that and you're like
i can't help you
the moment you've all been waiting for
but it's a shoe store sir
the moment we've all been waiting for
kids right now
me and mr mark bernardin are going to
recap
recap as in captain america and perhaps
uh spoil uh episode
five of falcon and the winter soldier
bam it begins now uh beautiful episode
um that i i saw twice already
um and adored and
i'm going to let you begin though mark
okay
um i want to smoke while i listen
and smoke one of those fine clove
cigarettes you hear so much about
smart kids tobacco no damn good for you
smoke clothes
indeed um this is this is what i
was kind of waiting for and we had
talked last week
about kind of my desire for us to
re-engage with this idea
that seemed to be driving you know the
heart of the show which is
can sam wilson can a black man be
captain of america
yes and you know and once you get
once you sit down on that idea as we do
in this episode for a good ten minutes
just sort of
talking about that very idea
um it was some of the most powerful
stuff
that that i'd seen a in this show and b
kind of all year
um and a little bit of context for me my
my grandfather
was born in 1900 um he's since passed
but he was he was a century baby
um and i remember when i was a teenager
and i don't think i was actively for
real thinking about during the military
i might have mentioned it like watching
some commercial
or something but i remember like and at
the time he would have been 80 something
years old
he just turned to me and he said listen
a black man has no place in the military
they took so much from us already don't
give them everything
and you know that clearly has stuck with
me now
30 or 40 years later and you know for
context again he was 80 years old
but he was a man who had living family
that had been slaves
so it's a very specific perspective but
you know and and to see isaiah bradley
have this conversation with sam
talking about the the sacrifices that he
gave to a country
that would not return at the very least
dignity
let alone prosperity you know talking
about the tuskegee airmen you know
flying hundreds of missions and saving
thousands of lives and coming back to
america to get you know
spit on and have things thrown at them
in the street you know to talk about his
his experiences like he did the same
things that steve rogers did
the exact very same thing rogers does in
captain the very first captain america
and where steve
is hailed for it isaiah is jailed for it
yeah thrown into prison for 30 years so
the woman that he loves dies without
ever seeing him again
like the heartbreak of that guy
and and absolutely his position
is legitimate and understood which is
why
why would i want to claim my right
as you know a super soldier why why
would i want
to to wear the colors of a country that
has done me wrong
every chance that it had you know
and of course like it seems kind of
clear that by the end of this show
he's going to open that box and inside
the box is going to be
wakandan wings and a uniform and it's
all going to be red white and blue and
we know that sam is going to put on that
uniform
and be the new captain america because
he believes [ __ ]
spoilers man
i'll be honest with you at the beginning
of this episode i wasn't
sure there's a really insanely moving
moment in the beginning of the episode
where
sam has the shield back after the fight
with
john walker and and and uh bucky
and he sees the blood on it and starts
trying to
wipe it off and it's really [ __ ]
poignant because you're like
wash it you wash all you want sam like
it's not gonna go away
yeah so at the beginning of the episode
i was like
they might be [ __ ] doing away with it
like maybe they do take a shield and
turn it into the wings or whatever
the [ __ ] like and in a world where
marvel is
like pushing you know the story forward
and never just
letting it be the same old thing for a
second
like for the first half of the episode i
was like holy [ __ ] man they might get
they met like the shield go
then by the end of the episode i too
got a real sense that he's he's gonna
put that suit on and he's gonna become
captain america but hats off to the
storytelling that had me doubting
the inevitable conclusion yeah you know
and i think that that
it's uh it's incredibly well done right
like when anthony mackie is bringing the
heat
the writing is super strong overseen by
malcolm spellman
you know and and direction as is the
direction
for sure like there's so much at work
here in this episode
but you know that sam is you know he's a
fighter he says it as much to his to his
sister that he thought he was going to
be the one
to change the world and he still
believes that
um you know and ultimately it's going to
be can he prove to america that a black
man is worthy of carrying that shield
but that proof has already been given
like isaiah proved it
you know he has already proved it um
you know and the thing is that it's not
it is not up to sam to prove that he's
worthy of the shield
it's up to america to prove that it's
worthy of his service
of his sacrifice and ultimately his
forgiveness you know like is america
worthy
of you know black kids wanting to play
as its mascot you know there's some
really beautiful moments where
you know his nephews are just like
playing with the shield because yes
they've loved steve rogers and
absolutely you would pick up that shield
and if you could play with cap's actual
shield in your house wouldn't you
you know if you could come close to it
and touch it and feel the sort of
history
in it wouldn't you yeah none of them
running around with [ __ ] fake falcon
wings on
but you know it was really touching
moment and what nothing i ever connected
but it was definitely intentional
was when they called him uncle sam and i
was like
yep oh of course he's gonna be [ __ ]
captain america he already is he's uncle
[ __ ] sam
yeah you know and there's no way for
this show to have known
that it would come out when it came out
but you know there's something really
sort of poignant and moving and
incredibly relevant
about us watching this episode at the
end of a week that began
without seeing footage of an afro-latino
man
in uniform guy named caron rosario who
was pulled over and pepper sprayed
in uniform yeah for no other reason than
he was black
you know and so is that the same kind of
world
where that person would eventually not
just get to be captain america but even
want to be
you know and so i really appreciate that
this is a show
that is dealing with all of this like on
front street like we're not even hiding
it weird
it's just text not subtext it's not
hidden
it's this is what this is about the
thing that i'm a little worried about is
that
it will ultimately let america off the
hook
because yes sam's going to be captain
america and yes he will probably prove
that he's worth it
but it's it's not for him to prove
you know it is america in both this
fictionalized version of it and in the
real version of it
that needs to find its way to understand
its own problems um
without the presence of somebody else
fixing it for them
um so yes that that is that is my
like deep feel about this episode and
and it's provocative in all the right
ways
um beyond that like i just really
[ __ ] liked it
even apart from that stuff you know i
love the john walker stuff i loved
you know his his feeling of privilege
like
i'm supposed to be captain america i've
lived my life
training to be captain america you can't
take this away from me i'm what you made
me
i'm going to be captain america whether
you say i can or not
you know like i i love the stuff when
bucky comes to
to new orleans or or louisiana to come
and hang out and
fix a boat like i love that this old
boat episode
of [ __ ] winter soldier we're just
rehabbing some old [ __ ] come on guys
let's sand some wood
also like the boat you know bring the
community together to repair the boat
which was a lovely note
in and of itself and getting to watch
bucky flirt with sam's sister
it was kind of a metaphor for like you
know no one person
if if you look at the boat as the shield
or the mantle of captain america it's
like no one person is going to do it it
takes a
community and whatnot and perhaps it can
be
saved like you know if the boat boat's
got to be some sort of [ __ ] metaphor
like sam's trying to give away the boat
because it's the past or whatever
because it's like hey it don't belong to
me
and his sister's trying to do the same
thing with the boat and his sister
arrives at the conclusion
i should keep the boat at the same time
that sam arrives at the conclusion
apparently that
maybe he can carry the shield but what
is the
dog fight outside what what um
what do you like i mean this is a
ridiculous
question but this is kind of [ __ ] we do
here is i after that big speech
isaiah gives him is isaiah
disappointed if sam becomes captain
america
i kind of feel like he would be you know
it's like i told you my story
you've lived your life you know the
story why would you think this would
change
what evidence of the past has told you
that anything going forward will be
different
you know and for sam it's got to be hope
right it's got to be like i have to
believe that if we work at it
if i believe that we can all come
together and do the work we can take the
rotten things out
and we can replace them with new things
it can be our own ship of theseus
and still be the thing we want it to be
don't mix [ __ ] show metaphor
because they're literally working on a
ship and it's like can we make this
which we know is broken and we know it's
tarnished and we know
is is is rotten firm within can we fix
it
all of us together and if we're willing
to do the work will this boat still sail
and you know do we rename the boat of
course we don't
because this boat belongs to us it's our
history so we have to be mindful of that
while still finding a new way forward
you know it's all
you know it's all very much like it's on
theme
this it's a thing that you know you're
always thinking about when you're
writing
is how is what this scene doing
helping to tell the overall story that
we want to be telling and every moment
should be doing that
it should either be on theme or on
character or on plot and when it's what
it's working well it's all of the above
the uh uh uh
zemo watch has come to an end kids
because we've watched zemo
go off into the sunset uh lovely scene
at the sokovian memorial um
where once again bucky gets to prove
that the winter soldier part of him
is completely expunged uh zemo watch
graphic one up
oh that made me laugh um but uh daniel
bruhl like just [ __ ] owning it
just incredible and i love that he
didn't zemo didn't get killed
he never put the mask back on but
didn't matter because the zemo they gave
us he was completely
true to the character you know [ __ ]
double dealing
[ __ ] like that um the uh
he gets taken away by the wakandans to
the raft
but that's you know if you know your
marvel history kids that's just
set up because at the raft he's going to
be under
the [ __ ] surveillance of general uh
thunderbolt ross thaddeus himself
who may just have an idea or two about
putting together his own
super team so that was as soon as she
said that
she was like we're taking him to the
raft i was like
you do that yeah it's all gonna be fine
don't worry everything's gonna work out
um
the other big intro of the episode of
course was
julia louis-dreyfus coming into the
marvel cinematic universe
as uh well she got a lot of names but
let's just call her madame hydra for
heaven
this character goes way the [ __ ] back in
in
the history of the marvel universe and
and was like
an agent of shield with nick fury and
and agents of shield
uh in the comics i'm not talking about
the you know the tv show
uh turned out to be a double agent agent
working for hydra turned out to be trey
hydra
later on to leviathan but her you know
most famous name was madame hydra i
think later on she became viper after
left to hydra but um what a
what a you know left field
kind of like oh okay
i mean the same way they introduced
agatha harkness
in wanda vision who's going to be around
for some time
they've now introduced another high-end
villainess um who i understand was
supposed to debut first in black widow
right but you know because they moved it
now she popped up here first
but uh i wonder if they'll do like her
relationship with
nick fury because in the comics she and
nick fury were a thing
you never can tell they absolutely could
and should
but he's [ __ ] wonderful i mean most
people of course are like seinfeld but
like
her as veep is some of the most biting
[ __ ] comedy you've ever seen in your
life and she is
[ __ ] flawless so she came in
very selena meyer into this uh
into the scene and um you know provided
us with
a bunch of information you know
breadcrumbs but information nonetheless
and she knew that walker took the super
soldier serum as well
and also the like a little secret um
the shield doesn't really belong to the
united states like it's a gray area
it's wakandans it's the material had to
have been taken from wakanda
and wound up in the care of uh stark of
the senior stark
um but yeah ultimately in a world where
you were
you know turning over items or artifacts
stolen from other
countries in the midst of war as happens
that
all that [ __ ] belongs to wakanda they
could have taken the shield last week
when you know
like lethal technically it's all theirs
they painted it funny we don't want it
interesting notion though to bring up
and and to add you know what i'm saying
like
nobody drops that in without wanting to
use that information
yeah i mean i think it's it's all part
of the the john walker
arc you know because there he's at his
lowest moment where he's been defrocked
by the government and just sort of left
with his wife
um you know and the idea that the shield
itself is not
american and hence is not what makes a
captain america
is what's on his mind and so that's why
you get that scene
in the middle of the credits our first
mid-credit sequence um
on falcon winter soldier where he's
welding his own shield
taking his medals of honor and and
hammering them into the
surface he's he's forging just like
tony stark did building he's built as
tony stark built a hero and
and uh john walker is building the us
agent
um also shields hold on before we go
there
listen i thought this was interesting um
fna presents on chatter said
kevin do you know about the sharon
carter phone theory you know they showed
sharon carter this week and
she was hiring the truck yes and the
intimation was like she had hired him
the first time so you're like what the
[ __ ]
so but this is interesting um villains
cannot use iphones
heroes use them but she does not
are apple products not allowed to be
filmed in the hands of bad guys
i think that's true um
i'm trying to think if i know i think
that's one of the things is you
like the apple an iphone can't be used
by the villain
so i mean i i believe it sharp
i guess what they're saying is uh sharon
carter did not have an iphone i just
assumed it was because she was in
europe but they got iphones in [ __ ]
europe too so
you know it's something to think about
not europe where is she she's in
metropoor yes high town um
um we had we had two scenes two
sequences
with uh with sam and a shield the first
sequence
is sam and bucky and it's really really
strong you know it's
it's the experience you know and it's
the extension of that
therapist scene where you know they
finally come on the other side of it
where you know bucky is admitting that
you know
when he and steve discussed which we had
never known before
that old man steve and bucky at some
point had sat down had a conversation
about the shield
and old man steve wanted to give it to
to to sam
and bucky thought it was a good idea and
then said we never considered what it
would mean for a black man to carry that
shield
yeah for that i'm sorry you know we just
didn't know
the the the the contours of that
relationship that that black man would
have with a this country and be with
that piece of
metal um and then getting to the the
reality of bucky's list of amendments
and how he wasn't making amends he was
avenging things and he needed to
he needed to ultimately as well i'm sure
we'll see in episode six
go to that old asian man and tell him i
killed your son
and that's why he never came home and
i'm sorry and i'd like to beg for your
forgiveness
um you know and that's a great scene but
during that scene
they're flipping that shield around and
they've been doing it for years like
sam's flipping it and catching it
bucky's flipping it and catching it like
it's not a problem until bucky leaves
and sam forgets how to
use the shield and now we get the rocky
montage of him like oh this works
and like i woke up behind me i might
kill a child because there were children
running around that house
and he's whipping this thing at like a
thousand miles an hour and not catching
it
sam shield safety man come on
yeah really well he's training it was
weird right but i mean
it's one thing to play catch it's
another with someone else another thing
to play catch by yourself
um it's brought to you by manscaped take
care of your balls ladies and gentlemen
um the uh we have one episode
left indeed i mean honestly between that
scene with isaiah and that
scene with uh bucky where he's like
even just him saying like me and steve
never thought about
like what it would mean to put the
shields in the hands of a black man or
something like that it's just like
could you imagine back when you watched
iron man thinking you'd ever get
this kind of storytelling yeah
like i i i remain impressed at the
levels to which marvel is willing
to push these characters into places
that
they never felt like they were going you
know that's not in a bad way like they
always could have gone this way
but in superhero fiction by and large
you're not dealing that much with real
world content
especially in adaptations of that stuff
you know and it feels like
not to say that one is contention to
relying on the other
but watching the boys in the second
season how it's dealing with things like
nationalism and extremism and and
propaganda
um and then this season talking about
things like you know race and class and
and who gets to be um one thing as
opposed to who doesn't
um and both one division and and falcon
winter soldier dealing with some real
[ __ ] heavy [ __ ] um and i think it's
it's very impressive
and and doesn't need to be a thing that
they do but that they're doing it anyway
is
is laudable double r dub gaming in chat
says the scene with walker and the mars
family was gut-wrenching
yeah that was [ __ ] heartbreaking yeah
his sister could smell it though man she
knew that he was [ __ ]
yeah like the fact that he's he's he's
lying enough so that he believes the lie
like if you tell the lie enough you
believe it's true he's like no i killed
i killed the guy who killed your son
they're trying they're tracking the us
agent
story pretty pretty closely like not
not like be for beat but like he's he
will now
you know tread the line as the extreme
captain america i i don't think they'll
kill him in the next episode
i think i think john walker is going to
be with us for quite some time
yeah i mean but the one thing that makes
me feel like i desperately want and
don't know if we're going to get
is season two you know like they've
they've never really
cut like i think we know there's no
season two one division because that
just spills right into doctor strange
too
but like what happens with these two
characters i'm sure they will at some
point
appear in other stuff you know like it
would be great
if there's a sequence in in black widow
where bucky shows up as the winter
soldier
like still brainwashed like that's
[ __ ] rad but
how does these stories track forward how
do these traumas
spill out how do these characters go go
on um
the most direct line is another falcon
winter soldier season two but i don't
know
they haven't announced it yet
um a lot of people in chat saying
there's definitely gonna be a season two
i i haven't heard anything about it
raspberries pointed out
all i really want is a full retelling of
isaiah and the flashbacks that was very
surprising
that they had isaiah sitting there
telling that story
and he's an incredible actor so he held
the frame
but you know in the same way that you
know wanda told this
wanda and her brother told the story
about the missiles falling
then years later in wanda vision we
actually got to see the scene recreated
he's a powerful enough actor where he
held our attention but like there's a
world where as he's telling that story
we're seeing it in flashback right but
hopefully hopefully they saw the way
people reacted to the story and the
character
and you know that's something they got
cooking for down the road man because
[ __ ] i'd watch the [ __ ] out of that show
yeah i mean there's there's there's 100
a season
of a tv show that is just captain
america truth
yeah like telling that story um but i
think you know one of the reasons why
you you stick with those actors and it's
not expense although
it is you know astronomically more
expensive
to actually dramatize that stuff than to
just have two actors talking about it
but the point of that scene is for sam
to register this information
because that's part of his
decision-making process and if you're
cutting away
you're not seeing it land on him you
know you're not seeing him
feel these body blows of like i thought
i knew what this was about i thought i
knew the country that i served
and you're telling me these things and
because you see it in his eyes and says
we got to do something about this
we gotta tell somebody it's not the way
it used to be we i i can talk to people
like that level of i have to do
something and if we're on another
image at that time i don't think you get
that that's why the guy's gonna direct a
movie kids because he knows how to tell
a [ __ ] story visually
um i don't disagree with that being said
i still would have preferred
yeah yeah oh my god show me the
flashback footage but they're smart not
to because
now they can cast they cast that up they
can grab a [ __ ] star or something
like that
go forward yeah um yeah man uh
another wonderful episode and they're
about to pun intended bring this [ __ ]
bird in for a landing with one more
episode yeah
then black widow will be the next thing
we get
no um loki i think is the next thing we
get that begins when
may and that's june 11th
nothing in may um we get the bad batch
star wars in may but nothing marvel
it's gonna be tough i mean that one
division [ __ ] falcon winner soldier
back to back double dose was
it was everything man but i look forward
to loki as well
yeah um yeah loki's june and then
and then black widows july do you think
uh
in the next episode sam you know we've
seen the uh
museum where's smithsonian that's for
the exhibit
do you think we see a isaiah bradley
exhibit
um it would be amazing if we did you
know like
even if even if it's in setup payoff
land
that would be you know something a
really nice scene of
there now being a section about isaiah
bradley and
and uh you know maybe him getting to be
able to look up at it or something like
that because his
his grandson becomes the
he's one of the young avengers it was
care patriot or something like
yeah i mean there's there's that great
scene i don't know how i don't know how
deep your doctor who
watching went but there's an episode
called vincent in the doctor
where where the doctor goes back in time
to um
to kill some monster that is haranguing
vincent van gogh
they call him vince evan goff in the
show and so they spend
you know 45 minutes just dealing with
vincent and vincent's various
and sundry like his good humors his bad
humors he eventually commits suicide
but the bipolarness and the roller
coasterness of his emotional state
is very much part of it and so at the
very end of the show
you know they then hop in the tardis the
time machine
and they take vincent van gogh to the
museum the musee de or say in paris
that has this amazing vincent van gogh
um
sort of exhibit and in the past vincent
like nobody gave a [ __ ] about him nobody
like he
died unremarked and unheralded um
and so they were hoping that by showing
him what
how much love there was for his work in
the future might keep him from killing
himself in the past
and there's this scene where you know
the vincent van gogh actor is walking
into a gallery of museums
with hundreds of people looking at his
art on the walls
and the curator comes over and the
doctor asks him like could you could you
like briefly describe
um vincent van gogh and the guy's like
he is in my mind the greatest artist
who's ever lived is use of color
informed you know
dramatized the the emotional content of
his mind and then you see vince and van
gogh listening to this guy talk about
him in ways he never heard
and you see him crying and you see him
feeling it and landing on him
that scene with isaiah bradley walking
into the smithsonian
where people are just all around him
like oh
we never knew like that scene i would
love that scene
oh my god i get that scene i i finally
wrote a scene
i finally marked it where i'm like give
me that scene
here's a [ __ ] thing that you should
do and that's so good
for a second you think that was the
ending
[ __ ] you know i said on the internet
you made it up
home run um well
um that's it's uh
they they've i'll be honest with you man
like i was not looking this was the one
that i was like
falcon the winter soldier i'll watch it
and they really [ __ ]
they wrote me in they [ __ ] really
wrote my wife she was all over that
episode man
like [ __ ] this is how you know she
likes a thing like [ __ ] at the end of
the scene all of a sudden she'll be like
she did that like multiple times during
the [ __ ] show and at the end of the
show i was like oh my god this is really
great
yeah and i said like you know when julia
louise drivers came in
after the scene was over i paused it i
was like that's how they're getting
[ __ ] like you
know what i'm saying like [ __ ] they
got me i don't care who plays [ __ ]
you know uh uh madame hydra but like
bringing in katherine hahn bringing in
julia wee dreyfus that's how they're
getting people like the last few
remaining people who are like i don't
watch those movies those are
those movies are for my husband or those
movies from my wife or whatever
they're getting you with like well
[ __ ] julia louis dreyfus is in this
[ __ ] thing
yeah like it's it's they're getting you
with like great storytelling
proof proof positive we just
started watching uh and we're almost
done with 20 minutes left to go
ant-man and of course falcon pops up in
in in the middle of the flick and
[ __ ] gem was like
like in you know the lighted way that a
fan would
[ __ ] react and [ __ ] like that so
show's working on her too and i thought
you know i thought after coming from one
division which was very
female character centric heavy and going
into the
you know sausage party that pretty much
is falcon the winter soldier that it
might turn her off and it's more
action-oriented and she's like you know
she's like i don't need to watch them
beat the [ __ ] out of each other but
she's been [ __ ] on board man so
they're bringing that demographic in
you know the [ __ ] the the crosstarm's
wife demographic
it's an important one to do and it's a
thing that marvel's been very good at
like even going as far back
as like william hurt showing up like in
you know iron man 2 and in the hulk and
then you get robert redford
you know like oh [ __ ] we got redford in
the captain america movie like suddenly
like there's a bunch of grandparents who
are like
redford's in a movie he's going oh all
right i guess i'll see what this is all
about
you know michael man or you're like man
if he threw in with them like that's
gotta
yeah it's it's gotta be worth something
like he's he's not a he's not a paycheck
guy
um and so yeah they're they're really
smart about doing that and so good for
them
uh and our two leads are wonderful
like uh it's not like oh my god they're
chemistry i've never seen anything like
it before
but they're just they're both separately
wonderful and then
wonderful together but like you know
they're both
doing exactly what they need to be doing
um do we think that do we still feel
like sharon carter is the power broker
or has contessa didn't you hear the
[ __ ] iphone theory mark
i did but i'm not saying that she's not
a villain but is she the villain
or is it madame hydra is actually the
power broker
uh i'm i hope it's neither and i hope
they you know in the last episode
they're like
and it's you know [ __ ] alfie woodard
or yes or yeah could you imagine or
um he's already played a marvel villain
technically
i know um she comes back around
yeah who i mean it would have to be
somebody who's high up in madrid
which might make them a mutant wouldn't
oh [ __ ] man wouldn't it be amazing if it
was like
[ __ ] you know because they call it
the patch act
it was [ __ ] wolverine from when he
wore the i [ __ ] patch and that here
so they cut to one the last shot of the
show is the power broker and he's just
like
get him out of here bub it's [ __ ]
tom hardy
um i but i you know whatever whoever
they let it be i'm [ __ ] cool with man
they've given me so much with the show
more than i
expected and hoped for and like they
actually got me engrossed i'm sad to be
seeing it
end in one more episode but uh we got to
see the wings pop out again
you know his buddy who's like keep him
when he's like what do i do with the
wing keep him
in the comics he becomes falcon nice
the next shopkin um so that was kind of
cute that felt like that moment in iron
man
where rhodey was just like next time
baby when he was looking at the war
machine
yeah it's like i mean i'm gonna get
recast but i'm coming back
yeah um so you know kudos to all those
good folks working on falcon and the
winter soldier
you you're you're satisfying you know
the easy marks like literally
mark wahl who's i would never say easy
mark would be your ironic nickname
like [ __ ] yeah like
like angel benelli or something for a
guy who strangled 28 [ __ ] people
that's easy mark yeah nice guy eddie
why do they call him easy mark because
he's anything but
um for an easy mark like myself
uh you know that's it's not too tough to
grab me
just do the right things play the right
chords man and i'll [ __ ] react in a
pavlovian fashion but to be grabbing my
wife
again one division made sense to me
because i'm like well
you know [ __ ] female lead and who
don't like [ __ ] lizzy
but now i'm like you know she entered
the show going like who is this one
what else has he been in i'll judge you
know like [ __ ] i'm like sebastian stan
he was in the [ __ ] uh tonya harding
movie with [ __ ] harley
in the martian yeah was it martian yeah
he's one of the guys on the ship
i even know that i was like he's mostly
been in these marvel pictures man but um
now she loves him she's like oh my god
he's adorable and
really great actor same with anthony
mackie going into it
she was just like he seems full of
himself and then when he popped up and
[ __ ]
you know uh which mccall um
ant-man he's like oh it's my favorite
i like him so nuts
um to be fair she was she he had worn in
on her on
captain uh and you know in uh
winter soldier like captain america too
like at first she was like oh
and then she was like oh he's charming
um and he has been
he's been really charming
i mean this is the guy who was in like
you know
he's ready for to lead yeah he's been a
lot of [ __ ]
he's done his time and started like you
know not in the world of big budget but
in like
you know legit small indie film and
stuff
um all right falcon and the winter
soldier continuing to
[ __ ] murder my thirst
free commercials for liquid bro um
all right that's it for
uh falcon the winter soldier do we have
christian or do we not have christian
we do have a christian jc bamfin here
and let us
let us know what's going on man all
right
i can bring christian in you guys ready
[ __ ] yeah we're ready ladies and
gentlemen welcome into the show the man
the legend behind the shmo down give it
up for christian harloff christian you
there
i'm here what's up guys how you doing
hey man friend how are
you good i i was listening to the whole
thing and like
i i'm like [ __ ] i wish i could just
stop a winter soldier right now [ __ ] the
shimona
but like no you know it's funny kev my
my wife was the same way like she
actually she didn't like
wanda vision she bailed on it um she
bailed quick
and she's like yeah i guess i'll try
this one too and she
like last night she loves it and like
what you said
with like when you get those comments
from people who don't who just refuse
to watch comic book movies or who say
that oh this is silly or this is just
popcorn [ __ ] you're showing this
like this is everything mark was talking
about with like this is
like for me when i look at something
like a district nine that movie when you
look at that film
and you look at what the the messages
with apartheid and everything like they
they push it together
where it tells the story inside of the
science fiction where it's not just
beating you over the head with the
message it makes sense within the story
and that's what this is doing that's
what this has done because of everything
how relevant and
what's going on and even that one line
that they say like how long do we have
to die for this planet for them to take
us seriously you know like that
that keeps going on and like when you're
watching all this stuff with isaiah and
when he says to him at one point no
self-respecting black man would take the
shield
and then you look like you guys are
talking about what's he gonna do at this
point his philosophy he sees and he
sympathizes with isaiah
but then there's other that other side
of it when he's like
yeah but i i see i want to feel that
there is
that type of good and i do know like
there are people who
can help me can help it can get that
scene that kevin just created with
with isaiah who can who can make that
possible um
so this this series has been something
very very different that i don't think
anybody was expecting and how
like serious um and um
relevant but but still not beating you
over the head and the fact that like ah
we're just going to tell you
what's going on right now because we
this is this is how we're feeling right
now and you should know it
disregarding the story this doesn't
disregard the story it tells the story
and i thought it's done
really really well what is the protocol
in sam suddenly deciding to be captain
america being that they chose
a captain america so like if he just
puts on
the suit and starts swinging the shield
like
can the government be like no well i
think that ties back to what uh
what madam hydra was saying they it's
it's a tricky subject
they they really got their shield it's
not their shield they really can't
really
so he'll be a captain america that is
completely untethered from the
government
sounds like 100 and i think what's
what's funny is that
at the very end what that little scene
where um
walker's making that shield it's like
yeah it's a cool moment but
it's like we're seeing a real lightsaber
and then a dude building it at
disneyland it doesn't have it's not the
it's
you know what i mean it's not that
wakanda it's not this it's it's so
but it's more about the symbolism and
the fact
that steve rogers never had to say not
once
i am captain america this dude says it
while he's taking a piss
like you know every five seconds so
uh i thought the parallels are real good
and then the parallel like you guys are
talking about again with isaiah
and the like all that [ __ ] that he went
through steve went through
but steve was kind of was yeah that's
captain america look what he did let's
give him the slow motion and the music
when he's coming back in but isaiah
we're locking him up
and it and even his wife same thing same
parallels
one lost lost the love of his life for
years gets her back
not this guy this guy is sitting there
and like and just
has his garden you know what i mean he
doesn't get his dance with a puppy
moment
he's got his garden and his and his
grandson which i think that europe's i
think he they're
absolutely going to bring his grandson
into it and i
and i think that they're oh and you guys
were mentioned in torres
i think torres is the underrated gem of
this whole
series like i hadn't even heard of this
dude i know he's in like top gun or
something but i never
heard of him um he was he came across
very real
you know he's fantastic a show where you
know
it's one guy's got a [ __ ] robot arm
wings guy who's got
you know [ __ ] weird wings and he
could fly he came across very natural
and charming as well
and kind of like i i didn't realize it
until this episode when he said keep him
with the wings
that i'm like oh he is sam in
captain america winter soldier the same
like he was to steve torres is to
sam kind of feels like the relationship
it's like passing the baton is like and
this whole show
i'm a big uh 80s action guy and like
lethal weapon and and the loving the
fact that they turned
zemo into leo getz like i love all that
stuff right i guess it's
like he's leo goetz he's oh that's such
a like a great
deep cuts yet not deep cuts because it's
so mainstream
reference well he's so leo gets i mean
you think about everything because
he leo gets i was always was he was a
criminal but you loved him because of
the way joe
pesci played him and zemo was the
villain in civil war but
you're not rooting against zemo he
shoots a dude in the middle of the
ah that's zemo being zemo you know it's
at this point and
even when he comes back i don't want to
see him be a villain again i want to see
him kind of helping out a little bit
more
because and and the other thing and i'm
sorry i know that we're supposed to be
talking about other things here but like
i
but i'm just so i this show like has
really started thinking about it with
with carter the thing with her is that i
don't think
that she's the power broker because she
they want evie dead power broker wants
her dead
and she's sending george st pierre to
help her out
yeah she it feels like in a world where
they just
introduced madame hydra who is a triple
agent minimum
i feel like sharon could be a double
agent who's like
trying to survive and throwing
this threat to you know the enemy of my
enemy
dot dot dot kind of thing and stuff but
the the point that you make about
um you know [ __ ] zemo being leo goetz
is
fantastic dude he was he was very he was
one
all we needed was an eastern european
they [ __ ] you with the driver
all right he's doing the dance in the
club and it's like i'm like yeah that's
that's
that's leo goetz and he's got his what
do you want leo gets
21 leo gets
the whole way through even with that
speech at the end
it's not like he was ever like i was
wrong he's still committed to
you know you can keep that character
going as a guy who's like i want to see
superheroes stopped particularly if they
take him in the
direction that it looks like they're
going yeah putting him on the raft and
heading toward thunderbolts land and
stuff i i i know this is probably
blasphemy with you with youtube guys but
like i
my i was i was always such a big movie
guy growing up and movies was
like the thing to me that i i mean [ __ ]
starting the movie trivia mode but like
i have found within streaming
over the last couple years what is able
to happen with characters like to me
it's it's empire strikes back and then
it's uh
it's it's new hope and then it's
mandalorian for me because there's so
much
development inside of those characters
and i feel the same about
this show because i liked falcon
i liked the winter soldier before oh
that was cool those guys showed up but i
know so much more about them now
because i would just watched a six-hour
movie with them i was able to get stuff
like that in the boat you can't have
scenes like that for the
inside of a movie that's gonna cost 250
million dollars that you're going to
watch
because they're there to watch them [ __ ]
up thanos you know they're not there to
watch those scenes and you get that in
here and i found myself i care so much
more
and i want like star wars for me i want
star wars in tv from now on if we never
get a star wars movie ever again in the
theater i know i'm sorry but i
i couldn't give a [ __ ] i want to see i
like the development inside of it
and i'm starting to feel the same way
with marvel i think it's going to be
tough for both of them once they start
going back to work
as per normal because every movie
people make i mean we saw a little bit
with uh when they did
the you know the um uh
the last skywalker was that it
yeah the the with the little surprise of
skywalker yeah
yeah rise of skywalker uh mandalorian
was already out for season one and so
instantly people were like
i don't know man i like this this feels
more like a thing
i think you know i think marvel makes
incredible movies but i think now
they've
really spoiled us with storytelling over
six to eight
hours yeah that you know there will be a
lot of like
i don't know man like i don't like it as
much as a series and of course you're
gonna like a series more
because it's like here's here's you like
two hours you're six to eight right
with [ __ ] so i hope they don't
get judged against
the high bar that they've just raised
for themselves and yeah
i think that like going forward it seems
as if there's a really easy model for
them which is the series or the floppies
yeah and the movies are the annuals you
know and it's like here's the big
giant [ __ ] thing we could not do in
the series and we saved it for the
annual and so
and if they all feed into each other and
it's all dovetailed that way
right it'll feel like it's a crescendo
and you'll get a movie
and then you'll dip down again and
you'll do a series and oh cool [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] and then
movie unless marvel also has the benefit
of doing because their [ __ ] was set up
like a tv show anyway inside of the
movie series like they connected it
since iron man all the way through like
and and i think that now as they have
this they're gonna
get more subscriptions to disney plus
and they'll say well you know you don't
necessarily have to watch this but it'll
benefit you
if you watch one division and you watch
these other things because now you'll be
even more involved that's the benefit
they have is that their movies connect
anyway so
i i kind of backtrack a little bit off
of marvel not still doing movies because
they connected in such a way they have a
formula
star wars for me is that thing where
it's they still haven't connected
everything through the movies
granted you know obviously the the
characters but
but not the way i think more so you look
like ahsoka popping in and the way that
they did that these little
that's more of the marvel stuff right
the way here's ahsoka she's gonna have
her own series now but people who didn't
know her from clone wars and rebels
now you know her and you've introduced
her to this popular show mandalorian
that when you spin that off
i'm more invested and it's almost that's
their shared universe for star wars is
going to be the series
yeah we agreed um as you can hear
christian no slouch when it comes to uh
the world of [ __ ] we all
care about and blab about and stuff like
that which is i imagine
how the schmodown came to be christian
where did the showdown begin originally
so the movie trivia shrunk started on um
mark ellis and i were comedians at the
comedy store and
uh we became buddies and we started our
own channel called shmozno
on youtube we were reviewing movies and
we started a two-hour podcast like
before anybody was really movie-wise
anybody was really doing it so we
started doing that and we
were we had this segment last half an
hour of the show we
it was almost like we wanted to do like
the howard stern show for movies type
thing we were doing that kind of thing
we're going back and forth and
having like uh a crew that just [ __ ]
around and
let's do a march madness thing would
take our crew and we'll
pit them up like 16 16 competitors 15
weeks and we'll
do it live we'll see how it goes and so
we did it and it was re it's not like it
is today with all the rules and all that
it was and it was
fun the audience loved it and then we
did it again we did it the following
year we did it for teams
and we all the end of the first season
we brought the maria menounos who we
were working with at the time was
working with wwe and she got us this big
ass wrestling belt
so she was like and it was like the
legit one so the winner mark reilly who
won the whole tournament uh got it so
then we did it with teams
we wanted to open it up a little more so
let's bring in [ __ ] from like
rotten tomatoes and ign and
and start to do that like a kumite type
thing right so
so so we did that and then i started
working for um
for collider and i pitched the show to
uh john campbell at the time who was
over there and he's like
and i said dude i want to do this like
the ufc but i want to do it weekly
and i want to like pit the best of the
best and open it up and we do it weekly
we have some fun
and i had a deal with collider i had
like an open open like development deal
and they're like you can do the show but
you got to take it out of the money that
you have
and i was like if i own the ip that's
cool and they're like yeah do it so we
started we started doing the show we did
that it went to teams
and it just became a thing because i
wrote for the wwe a very long time ago
and i said what if we infuse
like we make this a show because trivia
after a while can get
boring you know we just do trivia
because okay that's cool that's fun but
if you make it like a sport
a mental sport and do like kind of what
esports did and we did that
but then let's take that and put some
characters and have some heels and and
baby faces and
and do this whole thing and we did and
the audience really
got involved with it they loved it and
we started like fantasy they started
fantasy teams and after shows and
and fast forward to today where we have
like eight factions we did a big ass
draft we've drafted at the comedy store
and we've turned we've really turned
this into a sport
and skybound entertainment from uh
who've done walking dead they got
involved so
what a lot of great things and then
obviously yourself coming on it's been a
it's
it's been a whirlwind to be honest with
you for those that uh have never seen it
explain it to them exactly what it is so
the movie trivia showdown is a it's a
game it's a it's a movie trivia game
where once again the best of the best
compete and you it's
there's a three-round format we treated
it like the ufc in that aspect where
when the ufc was starting to pop really
popular like 2005
and we did the three three-round match
for um non-title matches
so you would get eight questions in the
first round from
any genre movie could be animated to be
action movies could be kevin smith
movies could be anything
um and one point a piece you got 15
seconds to answer the question
and you can't steal from your opponent
then you get to the second round which
is the wheel round you spin the wheel
it can land and again you you can
strategize you can say oh well i know
kevin knows
uh you know meg ryan movies pretty well
so i can uh so i was
talked i i ran the whoopee category
crushed it
crushed it yeah crushed it spellbinder
for me
you crushed it and uh and so we had uh
so
kevin can choose two slices his opponent
can choose two slices
and you try to mess with each other to
say okay what if i i had this amount of
time to look at these movies and say
this and maybe i can throw them off but
you get four questions in round number
two
and it's worth two points a piece uh
unless you go to multiple choice then
it's one point
and you can steal from your opponent in
that round third round you get three
numbers like i'm gonna pick number two
number one and number three you get a
two-pointer a three-pointer and a
five-pointer
and then you just try to it's it's what
you know and how you know it and
and you try to out score your opponent
get three repeats um but you have
managers now
kevin is managed by uh koi zhandra of
the quirky mercs
and it's like they they go we're doing
like this big thing for a faction prize
at the end of the year
um there's trades there's free agency
there's deadlines there's all of this
stuff
and that's kind of how it works the uh
mark did it first he went before me
because by the time i did it
i think like years ago schnepp john
schnepper's
mutual friend john the great sweaty and
sweaty himself
um had said you should go on schmo down
you would love it you'd be perfect for
it and stuff
and it took many years for it to happen
but it happened after mark
had done it first and mark had me pissed
scared not to do it
[Laughter]
he said the question that they burned
him on was like
[ __ ] what were the names of the bad
guys in the world
and i was like are you [ __ ] me like
i know
movie trivia but oh god i can't do that
but and then i finally did it
and i thankfully didn't mark it i didn't
get a question that [ __ ] difficult
um but i had a blast i've done it like
three times now
yep and it like you treat it like
everyone's having a good time with it
and you know you try to have fun with it
but you also like you're in the middle
of
like a real skill test particularly for
a 50 year old man who's like
let me pull up old data from a [ __ ]
weed riddled brain
a really good exercise for a guy
who loves to like you know i'm one of
those people that like
if i don't remember it somebody's like
well let's google it i'm like no no no
man that's what our brains are for look
i'll find it just give me a minute and
[ __ ]
so i've had a blast [ __ ] doing it but
mark tell them about your
ill-fated experience i mean i i had fun
also but
the thing that i realized you know doing
it was a was a ton of fun
but b there were people who took it like
really really seriously
like you know talking to some other
competitors and some people was like
yeah i gotta i gotta bone up i gotta
watch some team movies this weekend i
gotta
i gotta do some reading i got i gotta i
gotta grind i gotta crush some data
i'm like i'm just remembering [ __ ] i
might know
well mark you guys i heard you in the
beginning you're like i know christian's
gonna try to sell me when he comes in
uh and you are 100 correct
but but i'll tell you what because like
when you when i hear you talking about
it you remind me of like ethan irwin
right ethan irwin
is the president of silver pictures he
runs silver pictures right you know now
the
joe's gone he runs it he's like you he
doesn't study
he knows what he knows and he just plays
right and and there are a lot of people
like that that do the same thing
the cool world scenario was a very
different situation because at the time
we had we had one writer and god bless
him he was doing everything
i've since since being with skybound who
have have an opportunity to have
more more people more writers and we've
said the same thing we want to make this
show fun for the audience and fun for
the for the competitors right so it's
like so there's certain times like
i said asking a question that someone
has seen once
about a movie they maybe saw cool world
once on cinemax a long time ago
no one's gonna remember the villains
like that type of stuff doesn't happen
as often anymore in the infancy of that
type of stuff right so
and imagine this when it's like and i'm
announcing ladies and gentlemen the team
of
kevin smith and mark bernard and the
team together come on you guys the fat
man team would be incredible
it'd be incredible
they'll love the answer and the other
guy's gonna [ __ ] all over here
that's your answer kevin really that's
where he went great
but you know it's it is you know we we
do it is taken seriously because the
thing is
i want to make it very clear that if
you're trying to set up something
you know especially like think about
esports or whatever it might be this
isn't bar trivia i mean it isn't and
people right away when they say because
we're only seven years into this thing
so when people think they go oh movie
trivia you can't take that seriously at
one point it was like what are you doing
you're hitting what
you think what do you call it baseball
what is that football oh
it started somewhere and like when i the
reason why our lifetime in our recent
memory
ufc began yes yes
93 people were like well that's not
really that's that's not
official that's and now [ __ ] it's a
billion dollar industry they called it
human [ __ ] fighting they called it human
[ __ ] fighting when it started and now
it's like the most popular combat sport
out there because
but the reason why is the way that uh
dana white and the
frederick brothers handled it in 2005
and getting it in front of people
and treating it like no this is a sport
and believing in it because you have to
believe
in what you're working on because i love
this thing but you ask my wife it's all
i
it's all i do is that's all i talk about
it's like my third child and
the reason why is because i've seen the
way people react to it at live events
when you
we've sold out in new york we've sold
that in chicago and when they go there
it's as if they're at
a wrestling match or or at a ufc fight
because they have their individual
um people that they like they're there
to root for them and it's not just
trivia it's a
it's a show we have scenes we have story
arcs we have all that stuff the trivia
itself
is legit because i have to do this kind
of choose your own adventure stuff to
where if i have a story angle of where i
want
to go with it if someone loses i gotta
go oh [ __ ] i gotta pivot now and i gotta
go this way
and that's that's the fun of it as a
creator for me to be able to do that
kind of stuff but like i had friends
in brooklyn come out and see it to be
there to support me
and they were there and they were
watching dan merle who is the uh current
movie trivia schmodown champ
and he's five-time champion merrell who
has like [ __ ]
for forgotten more about movies than
most of us will ever
know in our lifetime it's insane man
this guy is so good he's like the
michael jordan of the schmodown he's he
is
dude he's very sweet he's one of my best
friends he's a great dude
and so he um he's out there and
he's answering all these questions and
he played against ethan irwin
so my um he took the title off ethan i
think was the third time he won his
championship so my friends came up to me
afterwards dude i didn't know a
[ __ ] one of those questions i didn't
know any one of them but i'm sitting
there going how does that guy
know that how does he do that you by the
way using kevin is kevin's match by the
way if you didn't know and you want to
see it his
latest match with stacy howard just
dropped today on the shmo down channel
um but it and that match everyone had
you dead to rights against
stacy they're like uh kevin's like kevin
played against the flirt and flowers and
chris jericho he's not gonna be able to
beat a top ten competitor
that's the type of stuff like it it
switches
the narrative switches like that now
everyone's like kevin smith's for real
kevin's for real it's amazing
it took me my whole career to be
considered [ __ ] for real
[Laughter]
it really was kind of it's each time out
it's been
fun and it suits the only strength in
this life i have which is an
overabundance of information about
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that i've sometimes even seen once
i mean i talked about it before but like
you know i i had i spun on to the whoopi
goldberg category and i had the choice
to
spin off it to something like there was
a ben and matt category
like that but like i was like you know
what
like i've been here for the entirety of
whoopi goldberg's career
and i've been watching yeah i think i
i think i'm gonna give it a shot and
then there was an arrogant tiny piece of
me that was this like
if i could run this category like it
really makes a statement beyond the
statement
maybe she'll call me
maybe word gets back and she's like good
thank you
kevin i met her once on the floor of the
new york comic con doing a piece for
like the the first i should say not once
first time i met her
doing a piece for um
one of the news shows or something like
that and
man she was [ __ ] lovely and like
geeky
as well uh so yeah yeah maybe i do want
to be friends with her mark maybe i
would like her because that's right
those [ __ ] stoner from what i hear so
like we'll do a new york event she can
walk you out
[Music]
but i was rather proud to run that
category i wish we had those questions
now
because i would ask my co-host mark
bernard and every one of them to see if
he
could answer the whoopi goldberg
question mark was no joke though dude
mark
when he was playing mark was he blew it
on cool world chris that was it
he called him the magic man he was the
magic mill and he was uh yeah but
he was he was in he was in one of those
free-for-alls where we do
where we do spin stuff very close like i
said we we do a lot of stuff off like
wrestling and we have we have a big
event coming up on the 24th and it's the
our version of the royal rumble and it's
it's called the free-for-all and it's
five people start at the desk there's 40
people in it five people started the
desk the least amount of points gets
eliminated until there's one person
standing
and it's uh the winner gets a title shot
the the
mvp of the whole thing gets three points
for their faction it's it's
it's a lot of fun we do a big thing at
the end of the year which is our
wrestlemania
so um it's a full-on season it starts in
february and ends in december so there's
a lot kind of going on with it
if they want to watch it right now they
go to your youtube channel schmodown
youtube channel
yeah you just go to youtube.com and uh
and click the subscribe over there we
have matches every wednesday thursday
and friday
of the league and you can kind of get
into it you could i would just suggest
maybe even watching the draft for people
but you know i can make a schmodown uh
announcement here
based off of your uh your stuff if you'd
like um
so kevin is now 3-0 that is not an easy
task to do in the showdown
because you still even though he said
well he played jericho in his first but
jericho played great by the way and
there's
nothing but jericho is a [ __ ] like
font of information
really good encyclopedic uh trapped
knowledge from 70 197
particularly every year he wasn't a part
of pop culture
he has filed away in his head he was
really really good and then you played
against the flirting places more
character but you still had to you
tko'd him you still have to answer all
your questions and you did that
and now with you being 3-0 i can
officially say that kevin smith will be
in a number one contender match for the
movie trivia showdown championship so
he's going to be playing
if he goes to 4-0 he's going to get a
potential shot to go up against
dangerous dan merle
i don't know i look that may be a little
fast for me
you were like this for a second i said
dan merlin you're like wait a minute
damn i thought i'd have a year or two to
work up to him
almost a year i thought i'd get to dan
in the sequel i didn't know i could
um all right man well like [ __ ]
that's huge honor
obviously and uh i welcome i look if i
have to lose to anybody
dance and dan merle [ __ ]
dead dancing dan merle as we call we do
the co-star of made in america with one
whoopi goldberg
bring it all back yeah thank god i never
would have remembered that thank god
that question was unveiled i had
eddie cause i couldn't remember what
sport it was about and i guessed
properly with basketball
yeah um all right so they can watch it
on their the youtube channel
what's the financial way they can
support schmodo
there's two if you guys want to um like
i said if you want to check out the free
for all we we go
the smodownlive.com is our website we
offer all of our pay-per-views that we
do there we do three pay-per-views a
month so we have all these matches plus
we have big pay-per-views that
then the matches will eventually air but
you can be there you can be live
watching with everyone
but we we treat our patreon more so like
a streaming service
where we patreon.com what we do is we
give away the
off again the wwe old network model
it's ten dollar patrons and you get all
three of the pay-per-views the
exhibition matches that we do
the special q and a's that we do um
there's so many more benefits
and that's and those are the tiers also
but you can join up and get all that
stuff too so
those are the big financial ways and
then we also at the skybox store you can
get the shirts because this season
when you get any of the faction merch a
percentage of the profits of those
shirts go into a big pool
that the factions play for and the
winning faction will get that
prize at the end of the season look at
that man yeah that's cool
that's a big old package um some they're
just telling me in chat that i'm an
idiot
uh because uh i don't fight dan next i
thought next
yeah i get a shot at dan or david that's
right yeah
number one yeah i've still got time oh
yeah yeah so the number one contender
match we
we have we have a few that that one i'm
not spoiling yet because we have a
couple people in mind
basically what will happen is they'll
they'll fight it out and then
most likely the title match should you
win that number one contender match
you would play the title in probably
august
would be would be the title match that's
good for me i'll be 51
man i'll be the underdog at age 51.
they're like no old man could remember
anything that ever happened in sin
it's true it's a recall that's the one
thing that the we call we call the
competitors mental athletes right
because
like as mark was saying like they do
take it seriously they go through prep
we had our former inner geekdom champion
kevin smith's
um who by the way when i voice call
kevin smith sometimes it calls you and
i'm like
and uh and so um it is um
he is an editor and he was he would
put on his headphones and he'd jog
around
um quizzing himself about about all this
stuff right and then he would
listen to it back while he's editing and
he's multitasking he's editing all this
stuff and he's just i don't know how
he's a brilliant editor he's getting
back and forth doing that he's listening
to questions
and he takes himself like very very
serious but the but the recall
the recall is the thing that that's a an
athlete has a busted knee
you know a a schmodown competitor
has a something pop in in their brain
they can't remember [ __ ] like matt
actually
who was rotten tomatoes uh like the
senior editor for a long long time
he's like if i was 25 playing this [ __ ]
i would be unstoppable because i can't
remember anything
it's absolutely true it does play a part
in a man where you're just like
and also being a blazer man like i'm
just burning away synapses
some of the ones that get burned away or
just like who played lily tomlin's
husband and the incredible shrinking
woman you know
oh yeah carl's grodden by the way but
still [ __ ] you never know there's
always the danger of it happening
right that's a 15 second clock i should
[ __ ] put my weed away
because i should train my only [ __ ]
muscle my brain
because that's the only way i'm ever
going to be able to
face up to uh dan like i don't know if
that's true you're pretty stoned out of
your gourd in the stacey match and you
look pretty great in that one so maybe
maybe that's what's working for you i
had a buddy used to get stoned
like he would he wouldn't play
basketball he was terrible he'd light up
and he's
hitting threes from like halfway down
the block
i believe it i believe it it does kind
of unleash something in me as well
and when it comes to true i think what
it is is the whole like
well i don't give a [ __ ] uh was it eddie
it was and i'm like
yeah and we also got the classic
argument that that's been i don't know
if you if
so on the after shows we have a show on
on the show network it's schmodown
rundown which is our espn
of the uh sports center of the showdown
and one of our commentators brad gilmore
he was talking about
your argument on the milk thing so kevin
had answered inside of it the life and
times of harvey milk for a bonus
question
the answer of it was milk i gave him the
benefit of the doubt i gave it to him
sam levine challenged it
they ultimately won the challenge
[ __ ] friend sam lavine
there's no friends in the schmodest
apparently not when it comes to this
[ __ ] he came in there going now come on
he said too many words i was like what
the [ __ ] in jeopardy i would have nailed
it as long as milk was in there it's all
good to go
but your argument was was the thing they
were talking about you're just like well
i
technically said the life and times of
harvey
milk
my presentational i teed it up i said
that was my mistake was teeing it up
i ranted i should have just simply stuck
with the answer but
it was i honestly a hail mary because
the whole time i was like
what movie was frank go in with [ __ ]
um um
john penn and i think the one i was
gonna go for was carlito's way and i
knew that was wrong
so then i was like you know what maybe
it's gotta be milk man
and yeah it was i was right but wrong
for some reason now you got me wanting
to watch carlito's way little david
confield
[ __ ] love that movie he's so good in
that movie
yeah he really is he's crazy yeah
um all right man so uh
go watch uh my if look if you're like
i'm still not sold on the shimoda what
the [ __ ] are you doing watching a show
like this for i'm telling you
right up your [ __ ] alley but if
you're still like i don't know i'm being
a smart shopper
watch my episodes and if you're not into
it after that then
i can't help you because you see the
pure bliss
joy you see my competitive nature come
out
when i did go after and defend against
that milk thing
like the lawyer in me came out like can
you see the shitty side of kevin smith
where i'm like oh no no one that got
thrown off the southwest airlines plane
that guy [ __ ] came out and stuff but
it's uh
they're so fun to be in i imagine
they're fun to [ __ ] watch and play
along with
and stuff uh excellent job creating uh
something that like you know all of us
are like why didn't i [ __ ] think of
that
i hope to god i texted kirkman because
kirkman is the
skybound king of course and uh with the
richest [ __ ] person we all know
easily a multi-billionaire as
ed brubaker agreed last week um
but uh i was like hey man we gotta do
something with schmodown man anything i
can do we go pitch it as a [ __ ] show
to put it on tv and stuff like that
and he had gone back to me and he was
like let's do this so
hopefully we get to push it uh out there
into the world it belongs on [ __ ] tv
in a world where people watch people
play [ __ ] poker on tv
right darts darts why the [ __ ] when you
watch this man cause you can literally
like play along and be like
get the answer in there and stuff like
that and watch people melt down
and if it gets popular enough someone
will start wearing a hoodie in all the
games or something
like they've that one guy they really we
we do that already we do that already we
had a gimmick already yeah oh
dude oh yeah i mean this this is the
difference you haven't seen because
you've been playing in the digital age
like
the guy i mentioned kevin smith's he
came out straight up goldberg with the
fog machine and the
and the hoodie over his head bouncing up
and down like like tyson in 86 right he
was
we we had guys like william bibiani
who's on your faction he came out in the
first uh
in this first match dressed up as a as a
killer with the song music coming out
there's a whole bunch of gimmicks going
on and like so there's there's a lot
there's there's something for everybody
if you like the story element if you
like just the trivia
it is there and um and yeah man we're
very excited for
what this season is it's just about
people knowing what it is and
and tuning in and catching it and we are
available on the podcast form too if you
just like to listen to the matches
and which you easily could now that i
think about it yeah
like oh my god you're driving you can
listen to the [ __ ] a lot of people do
that yeah we have it available
christian do you follow real sports at
all uh
yeah i mean yeah i'm a big i'm a big
yankee fan i'm a big uh new york giants
fan and
um what about the what about the fight
tonight with the internet boy
oh is is is paul is he fighting yeah is
he
who's he fighting i mean yeah i know i
knew isn't he always fighting but yes i
believe he's fighting for money tonight
well yeah i mean so who's is he fighting
the ufc guy is that what's going on
yeah yeah he's gonna get his head kicked
in literally
um i i was a big so to answer your
question i was a big
mma guy in like again 2005. i was
i i'm not ashamed to say i was i wasn't
working but i was betting on fights and
that's how i was making money you know
and
i was able to uh and i actually bet a
lot of money on matt serra when he won
the championship against george st
pierre and now fast forward years later
and we do [ __ ] videos with matt sarah
and it's it's incredible it was a really
good dude but
i noticed that they do a lot of these
things now the celebrities with boxing
they've always done that i remember the
late uh dustin diamond was doing that
back in the day with celebrity boxing
but it's
different even before dustin diamond
didn't rocky
charity fight somebody in one of those
movies
[Laughter]
hogan walks out and he says for all my
love slaves out there
it's thunder lips the ultimate mail
against the ultimate
meatball what is the and is for the one
with the robot happy birthday paulie yes
he's getting rid of it dude in his
in his cut you know he's doing he's
doing the the director's cut of rocky iv
and he's getting rid of the robot people
lost their minds
i think it's silly why would you cut the
who's he [ __ ] george lucas where he's
like
i gotta i gotta [ __ ] digitally remove
that [ __ ]
man i understand at this point the
director's cuts are about adding [ __ ]
not taking it out like yeah there's a
four-hour cut of this more robot
i think he's got he's added more i think
he's getting more in the serious tone of
it because
i was i'm actually all forward to see
what
i'm a big i'm a huge rocky guy so like
watching that uh
to see his cut and see what he's gonna
do i wish they'd do that for five five's
where we need a director's cut not not
four
we need we need even if it's reshoots
with his 80 year old ass fighting in the
uh
you know in the ring i'd still would
prefer the ending of rocky 5 be that
than the ending that we got
uh in the street fight um
if he's gonna lose anything from four
less of the training montage
yeah more more of the robot training
with the robot
yes what is my
snowbound training montage alone
they can trim a little bit it's very
intimidating for those of us who don't
work out
work out that hard but you know there's
paulie [ __ ] the robot footage
so put more of that in
that's right rocky's listening
he's using muscles he never knew that he
had oh take it back
kick it back
oh man um all right there it is kids
christian
the great christian harloth ladies and
gentlemen the king of showdown
uh go watch the [ __ ] out of it and and
watch go watch my match right now get
ready to watch
the next match coming up thanks for
having me appreciate it
for uh uh just geeking out with you here
on the show thank you
same here as always mark it's good to
see you as always man so i'll see you
man
yeah and thank you guys so much
appreciate it and look forward to that
next match kev and we'll talk to you
guys soon
yes you guys take it easy man better
guys hi christian
such a good guy um i'm telling you
that's
that
that schmow down is some fun [ __ ]
[ __ ] man
like it deserves to be on [ __ ] tv
like you know it's great on the internet
don't get me wrong i'm not saying like
oh it needs better but like
expose that [ __ ] to a bunch of people
who don't [ __ ] sign on the internet
anymore you know
i mean you know jeopardy's been on the
air for 98 years
yeah and not because like people are
like there's nothing else to watch
because people
every once in a while i like to sit
there and you know especially if it's
for [ __ ] half hours
use that part use that muscle and [ __ ]
indeed because it makes you feel
impressive you can't watch
real sports and play along like you know
if you're watching [ __ ] baseball
you're not sitting there going like oh
yeah
whatever but like you can play along
when you're watching a trivia game
because you can get the answer out
before the other people or just get the
answer period where a lot of people
freeze and [ __ ]
um but he's a good dude man um all right
we got i assume we'll have news won't we
we have a little bit of news it was a
slow news week up until like
yesterday i was gonna say [ __ ] a
bunch of news happened i've i caught
some
some spillover news on my phone if uh
if it's not me necessarily
um checking your work but if you miss
anything
i have a few that i [ __ ] okay
screenshot because i was like i was
right i was on taking a
if you must know i was taking my
pre-show [ __ ] and i was looking at the
news
and i said oh this is i didn't know this
i didn't know this and so i grabbed a
few just in case we missed them but
before i do anything
i've got uh i'm gonna grab a drink so
more liquid water in the other room yeah
my liquid death i
i murdered it so my thirst hasn't been
murdered in a while
and i'm starting to lift so let me give
you your stud up and you can start the
news ladies and gentlemen
this this this
this [ __ ] guy salt of the earth
[ __ ] good guy hell of a writer
and long before he was any of those
things he was he was
notching the news ladies and gentlemen
he'd noodle the news
he'd go out and sniff out the news he
was a newshound
and those instincts never die kids so
every once in a while when we do this
show the old newshound instincts come
out of our
writer friend mark bernardin and we get
to do the latest news so
mark that's a long way short of saying
mark bernard
here with the news mark what's the news
um well
hold on and for all you time code
terrorists out there
you know let them enjoy the interview
don't just tell them when the [ __ ]
news starts
like anyway back to you
they they don't appreciate a good segue
which we work so hard at building
they just want to jump to what they want
to jump to they all they want is the
[ __ ] money shot like
i said they don't want to they don't
want to kiss they don't want to do any
nipple work they just want to go right
to the vag
and like you know
the nipple work is where men are made
i'm just saying
and women women too i've heard
i don't know i don't i don't know if i'm
one of those guys
yes we want to be a broad-minded
uh pardon the pun all right start your
[ __ ] news i'm gonna go get me a drink
all right you should get you want you
want a drink yeah now hit me one
wouldn't that be amazing oh my god we
could easily set that bit up
where uh you know [ __ ] everyone's
like oh how cute but then
[ __ ] somebody on your side does hand
you a drink and people are like
what yeah or i just do the like i just
sort of
reach up out of screen and then out of
screen oh
thanks man this is great tell me if we
had that seth meyer's late night money
we could do that kind of [ __ ]
or like a little bit of forethought but
we can't even get [ __ ] a bamf
sound effect watch this jc bam finn
everybody be quiet
listen no noise
no noise whatsoever like a silent fart
in an elevator
again if we had planned this jc just
could have said
banff when he was you know what jc he's
gotta fight
that guy's got an excellent point every
time you
bump in can't you just go bam
while you do it
yeah done
that's what i'm talking about the show
just took the [ __ ] jump
yes yes time code that [ __ ]
and i yes [ __ ] mark that because it's
historic
the very first audio backed bamf
and i loved how it was done with the
least amount of [ __ ] enthusiasm
bam bam
uh all right i'm going to give me an
ollie pop tell me all right
the first thing is uh i noticed today i
think we broke out of today or yesterday
um dominic purcell who has been
a sort of steady mainstay of the legends
of tomorrow cast
seems to be leaving the show maybe
i think kinda um at any rate
he went on instagram and uh and and and
made two posts
i will read both of them now the first
one
uh says something to the effect of
deal isn't done i have no interest
whatever cash they throw on the
corporate level
i'm walking away it's been a total
pleasure and a humbling experience
bringing dc comics as iconic character
heat wave aka nick rory to life
well that sounds like a very promising
i'm ready for my next season type of
tweet
indeed i smashed this character
not an actor in the world could have
done better fact
such a funny [ __ ] i'm just reading the
words
uh referring to the funny [ __ ] is the
character he plays
um i think he's referring perhaps to
himself or to the character one or the
other
um somebody's very funny um and then a
couple of
um hey man not for nothing but [ __ ]
this is gonna sound like a low grade
commercial but it's not they're not
paying us a dime
have you ever had this a lollipop [ __ ]
no
i read about it and like online it was
like the healthy soda the doctors can
agree on and [ __ ] it's it's made of
plants it's got prebiotics on it
but my god there's no sugar in it it's
[ __ ] sweet as [ __ ] it woke me the
[ __ ] up
outstanding earlier was telling me i
should take pre-vegan but i think this
will do it
um yes so time to move on and see how
[ __ ] unfolds
katie lotz nick zano look after the kids
coming through they need education
they are a number teach them not to rely
on loyalty from the studio
the studio does not care the actors work
ethic and talent must give them the
confidence to question authority much
love to all it's not lost on me how very
fortunate i am
actors hit me up on dm which seemed a
bit like
the studios [ __ ] with my money and
i'm quitting this show
um i had a blast doing it but
you know hey whoever i'm leaving behind
needs to take care of the new kids
coming in because they're going to try
and [ __ ] them too
i'm out if you want to know more hit me
on the dm and i'll explain
which seemed to set off this sort of
like trigger
of fireworks going on in the press and
in the fan community that
dominic was unhappy and being mistreated
and and
and was leaving in a huff which he then
followed with another post
that uh that opens with why so serious
my last post i needed a laugh it was a
joke
the press went nuts and yes i will
always [ __ ] with the press it's fun
watching them be click baited
truth is yes i'm leaving cw's legends of
tomorrow
but we'll come back periodically it's a
handshake deal with my boss phil clemmer
i don't have a beef with studio um
r-o-l-f-l
joy joy emojis or warner brothers tv
i don't have a beef with anyone except
myself haha [ __ ] woke up this morning
like i caused mass riots
but what a genius negotiation move i am
loved
uh so wait is he on the show or not it
seems as if he is leaving
but he will return when
i guess he wants or when scripps dictate
or
he will go from being a regular to
special guest star
dominic purcell is what it looks like
you know if this always befuddles my
good friend jason muse
uh aka jay
island bob um he loves
these cw shows and i don't say that
facetiously
i mean he watches them and re-watches
them
obsessively they're his happy place
um he's been on one or two so he's been
on the set
you know of one of these one or two of
these few of these cw shows now
and invariably on the set you always
encounter somebody who
doesn't want to be there and that
baffles jason to nowhere he's just like
who would want to give this job up like
you know in his perception like this
is an easy job where you just get to
like you don't have to act
every day unless you're the lead or
something like that
and you know you're saying cool things
and they're making you do cool things
like
he it baffles him whenever anybody
leaves
one of their shows but it sounds like
this guy was he didn't leave he was
asked
to go did they didn't because bran did
the same thing happen to brandon ralph
where they were like well
thank you for your service there's the
door like
they just it's not like brandon was like
i want to get off this show they
just jettisoned brandon if i remember
correctly yeah i don't recall the the
context for his departure but
you know we talked about it before
indicated that it was
not his choice right i mean we've talked
before about the fact that the longer a
show runs
the more expensive it gets to mount and
the less people are watching
and so that will always result in some
level of
you know of departure the departure rate
will be higher because
look we can't give everybody raises all
the time you know we we got to
take care of our number ones and twos in
the call sheet and a cast like legend
tomorrow that was
massive there's gonna be some people who
just can't get taken care of
and so maybe this is that thing i mean
his first post made it seem as if he's
walking away
because the money wasn't right or
whether that was a sort of pocket veto
version of
them asking him to leave by you know
they've been in office space was like
let's just stop paying him
and he'll probably stop showing up oh
they built them do you think they melted
them they
could have mildened him who knows um but
it
in ore there's a version of i sent out
that first post
i got a ton of [ __ ] from the studio who
said that they're not gonna honor any
parts of my contract and just out and
out fire me
and then the second post comes where
it's like i was kidding
everything's fine i'm gonna be recurring
all is good
um please i'd like to keep getting paid
a little bit
i don't know what happened between those
two posts but
it's a weird flurry of activity on
legends of tomorrow
um you know the show has a giant cast
more so than than most and not just a
giant cast but a giant cast all of whom
are meant to be the main characters so
it's you know
it's always uh i would imagine i don't
[ __ ] know i've never
ran a tv show with live actors on it
that wasn't a cartoon
but uh i feel like balancing that many
personalities and egos and i don't mean
he goes like
you know they're all [ __ ] stuck up
and full of themselves just every
ego has its own you know way that you're
gonna
deal with that person everybody's
different and stuff and to have that
many main characters
you know you're dealing with a lot of
egos um
it's always to me it's a minor miracle
that they
you know run as smoothly as they seem to
run from the outside but i would have to
assume that in a world where
arrows wrapping up or wrapped up
supergirl is wrapping up this season
isn't black lightning also wrapping up
black landing is finishing its last
season i mean there's a spin-off coming
out of it but you know
who knows it could feel like legends may
be
next you know they've been on quite some
time
and you know they're they've got to make
way for some new shows and stuff the
superman and lois show did very well
ratings wise for him and it'll be back
after a bit they
they just didn't because of kova they
didn't get to shoot all their apps
they got uh naomi coming from ava
to vernet um powerpuff girls is coming
powerpuff girls is coming they uh is
that on the news or no
um no it was a couple of weeks back
they no we talked about the casting well
not the casting like
like two weeks ago there was a picture
of them shooting
in outfits that look like they were
purchased at a halloween store
and so the internet was uh you know very
very mad
and now the i guess cw released
images of the girls or the women
playing the power of the powerpuff women
if you will um
in the outfits in what they'll really be
wearing
and it was damn sight different than the
shot from across the square images that
posted on the internet but um so yeah
that's it it's more of a visual story
than anything else speaking of visual
story
this is a gift from bear mccreary
and it is
it's the revelation score
oh that's amazing isn't that cool it's
the it's the uh
main title theme and he wrote to kevin
by the power of grayskull bear mccreary
but this is the main thought so anyone
who knows music oh i shouldn't be
spoiling this
anybody who knows music could literally
[ __ ] read that and play it
and that score is amazing oh my god
oh my god kids oh my god uh anyway what
other what
what other news mark what hoe on the
news front
um amazon's lord of the rings show
looks like it's going to cost it's going
to come in on budget i hear
yeah i mean anything can come in on
budget if you're going to spend
all of the monies on it um the hollywood
reporters confirmed that amazon will
spend roughly
650 million dollars new zealand
which translates to 465 million us
for just the first season of the show
alone
one season and that season is not 50
episodes long
it's one season um and on top of that
don't forget may i ask a question edify
me please yes sir
this is a story we've heard before
no we knew it was gonna be expensive
are they just redoing the hobbit or is
this the hobbit
after dark or some sort of
sexy habits um no this
this is sort of you know that they they
haven't quite said precisely what it is
um they're the official descriptions
they just did mark
what it is is [ __ ] expensive
they better say what it is um
yeah it brings to the screen for the
very first time the heroic legends of
the fabled second age of middle earth's
history
um the epic drama is set thousands of
years before the events of the hobbit
and lord of the rings and we'll take
viewers back to an era
in which great powers were forged
kingdoms rose to glory and fell to ruin
unlikely heroes were tested
hope hung by the finest threads and the
greatest villain that ever flowed from
tolkien's pen
threatened to cover the world in
darkness so this
is lil sauron yeah this
is deep prequel business um and and i'm
not
fully uh steeped in tolkien
were there prequel books that i was
unaware of
there's a lot of information hey hey get
the [ __ ] out unless you're going to make
your noise get the [ __ ] out and do it
right bam spite
spider get me a drink all right come
back bam you're stuttering
so it's second age so it's not
silmarillion
it's the forging of the rings is what
they're talking about
so in the kind of epilogue or
prologue of the peter jackson movies
where they're like
we saw on forged the rings and he gave
him away
and everybody was deceived that's what
they're saying we're going to see
i mean look fine but you want to spend
every dollar ever minted
on on on that on the prequel like
hey kids remember lord of the rings and
all the characters you ever loved
they're not born yet
well but they're elves so they are
oh they're live so you get everybody who
is in you've got
everything you see here you've got the
elves and sauron
and and the like kind of magic
characters
you won't have viggo mortensen or or
you know frodo but you'll have gandalf
wait you won't have any [ __ ] hobbits
uh you won't have the hobbits that
you've seen
you may have like smeagle when he was a
hobbit
before he becomes gollum no you wouldn't
that'd
still be two the fact that you bumped in
tells me you're into this in some way
well the the onering.net which is the
giant lord of the rings show
does their show or used to do the show
before
our show at scum and villainy so i've
heard all about it
um that's that's that's a lot of [ __ ]
money man
it's a lot of money and it's just for
the first season mind you um
granted they will be building some [ __ ]
and fabricating some stuff that
might be used later so you can amortize
some of that expenditure
but that's a huge amount of money and
it's not taking into consideration the
fact that
amazon had already spent about 250
million dollars just for the rights to
make a show
and so now you're in it almost 600
700 million dollars all in before you
see a single
stitch of footage of lord of the rings
and it's
i think they have a five season
commitment
is what it what it was that's only but
that money is only for season one
correct correct so there's another four
seasons of 400 million dollar
300 million dollars to spend john monkey
on the chat says for comparison hanks
and spielberg
are plopping down 250 million
for 10 episodes of masters of
air the war drama similar to their band
of brothers miniseries
so two of the biggest titans in the
business
steven spielberg and tom hanks are doing
10 episodes of what sounds like a very
expensive [ __ ] show about world war
ii and it's only going to cost a
quarter of a billion dollars whereas
this [ __ ] lord of the rings show
is gonna cost how much 465 million
dollars
um 210 million dollars more
than the already expensive tom hanks and
steven spielberg
world war two in the air show wow yeah
i mean and of course [ __ ] kickstarter
to get your budget
where does all this money come from you
and me gotta start selling paper towels
and making jaws man
yeah like in comparison game of thrones
costs somewhere between 110 to 130
million dollars per season
and you know also huge cast of
characters also dragons and magic and
[ __ ]
um and they they will be so it costs a
lot of people their civility man with
that last season because boy they came
after it [ __ ] hard on the internet
people still
sore about that they put up a trailer
recently that had the internet
speculating that hbo
secretly re-shot the last season like
yeah they're celebrating the 10th
anniversary of game of thrones and
people are like why are we celebrating
this
but also like that there was anyone that
thought oh no hbo max
i think they might spring on us like a
brand new [ __ ] redone
season the final season because we all
didn't like it so much or something
that's why i kept reading and i'm like
do you honestly think if that had
happened that they wouldn't have [ __ ]
milked every piece of publicity off that
well in advance you would have heard
about the
every casting every [ __ ] pickup every
shot
whatever the [ __ ] like they would never
spring that on you they don't get
anything out of
springing it on you they want you to
[ __ ] sign the [ __ ] up so they'd be
telling you months in advance
so whatever it is i think it's just them
going hey remember game of thrones we
have it
yeah yeah there's seven seasons you love
remember that you can watch them all we
got it
uh what other news um
there was a rumor and i will classify it
as such
because i fundamentally do not believe
it to be true
that uh that disney plus is at work
on a wolverine anthology series
the reason i believe this not to be true
is that we decided well who's saying
that
i didn't hear that this was on a website
called the hashtag
show um and they are
exclusively sharing that marvel is an
early development on a series for disney
plus
the series would be an anthology based
on the character of wolverine since he's
immortal and has a multitude of stories
to tell
um seems unlikely
that's how they introduce wolverine to
the disney
marvel universe but uh you know yeah
it seems unlikely that a that's how they
do that and b
if a story like that breaks and nobody
else is re-reporting that story
like if that same news item doesn't
appear on collider or thr
or deadline or variety or any number of
other
news sources then it's not true
because they all would have called and
said hey we're hearing this
would you like to confirm or deny and
i'm sure they all said this is horseshit
and so they didn't even run with it so i
mean
good try hashtag you got yourself
mentioned on fat man but
um absolutely [ __ ] nothing i'll tell
you that
come after the show's done i go into my
bedroom tell my wife i was just on fat
man beyond she's just like grow up
so where's that anthony mackie fella
right
he's like him he's talented and he flies
um mark millar um who
uh i keep wanting to call him mark
millar
um but yes mark miller we we got our
first
trailer from jupiter's legacy which will
be dropping shortly
on um that's his
yeah i didn't know that yeah
so this is dropping in i think within
the next month on netflix
but uh word that uh another one of his
comics from the miller verse
called starlight um which centers on a
space hero who
who saved the universe 35 years ago but
when he came back to earth no one
believed him
um but of course he gets pulled back
into action um
to to one last ride sounds like a cool
story
sounds like a cool story um 20th century
studios is
adapting that into a feature and joe
cornish um
the director writer director he did
attack the block
is signed on to write and direct the
comic but can i
um yeah like and and honestly attack the
block is one of my favorite movies in
the last like 15 years or so
and and that dude does not work a lot um
he uh he last did the kid who would be
king
sort of teenage arthurian thing that was
actually really really good
i was surprised by how much i liked it
um and then has writing credits on
ant-man and the adventures of tin tin
so good on everybody involved i'm i'm
here for that
what else you got um there is going to
be an ancient
aliens movie have you ever watched
ancient aliens
you know on on the history channel it's
it's a show in which um
uh one dude this weird mad like greek
dude
um will always say hey pyramids did we
build them
or did aliens build them let's remember
our example you're gonna get into that
kind of talk mark i need to
settle my nerves with the smooth blast
of a clove
cigarette as well you should because it
feels like everyone involved in this
has partaken themselves of the clove
cigarettes quite a bit
um so yeah it's a it's a long-running
history channel show it's one of the
highest rated
you know shows on the on the channel but
it's a documentary thing much like in
search of but a little bit less
i don't know founded in fact um
but the fellows who made the cobra kai
one of your favorite shows are going to
direct and produce the feature project
based on ancient aliens now you have my
attention
why didn't you lead with that i needed
to give you
some foundational work i don't need so
much
uh you know [ __ ] what do they call
that
exposition mark i'm basil exposition for
you today sir
i'm a modern story uh audience member
you can skip all that [ __ ] unless it's a
marvel thing then [ __ ]
then give me that exposition then say
all those amazing names
fair enough um details of the project
are being kept under wraps but according
to legendary which is the studio
producing it
um it'll be a two-handed globe spanning
adventure featuring ancient sites and
artifacts confronting the theories and
questions
raised by the popular docu-series
um righteous look those cats [ __ ]
turned karate kid turned kobrakai to
a must-see for me one of my favorite
[ __ ] pop culture creations of the
last 10 years
i'll follow them anywhere like the same
kids you know did spider-man in the
spider-verse i'll [ __ ] follow those
guys anywhere
even if they were like we want to make a
story about the [ __ ] your murder
in real time you're gonna be like look
you guys make [ __ ] entertaining go ahead
yes so i'm in africa yeah i'm curious
because especially if it's kind of funny
you know if it's a bit of a comedy and
given that the cobra kai guys have a
very good sense of humor and still know
how to play
the sort of pathos and drama of that
stuff while still also being fun
they don't have to mock it you know and
they could just make it funny
you still having it be like you know
something you take seriously that's good
good for them
another [ __ ] job we don't have who's
next what else you got
uh the last story i got on the docket is
uh
hold on let me see here whisper it real
quick
avengers campus let me hit you with a
few more we'll end with avengers campus
fair enough what did you find joy
hummel the first woman
to write wonder woman okay
died at age 97.
all right p joy philip felix silla
who some people knew his cousin it on
the addams family but i knew as
the body of twicky rogers
he passed away as well and
the lady who played uh
uh narcissa malfoy uh
yes helen mccrory ellen mccrory and she
was also on
doctor who as well and peaky blinders
and peaky blinders she passed away
relatively young from what i understand
yeah in her mid-50s by the by the sound
of it oh what happens
anybody know i don't
i can check into it though
um yeah we lost some people this week
such a bummer
um but uh mark had the final story
i didn't want to end on like hey man a
bunch of people died
yeah oh yeah and helen mccrory was
married to
damian lewis the actor damian lewis and
the actor damian lewis
i'm 52 she died of cancer damien was his
wife
yeah he his statement says i'm
heartbroken to announce that after a
heroic battle with cancer the beautiful
and mighty woman that is helen mccrory
has died peacefully at home surrounded
by a wave of love from friends and
family
she died as she lived fearlessly god we
love her and
know how lucky we are to have had her in
our lives she blazed
so brightly go now little one into the
air and thank you
um man that's that's some beautiful
that's a beautiful sentiment especially
coming at a time
must be the absolute worst time in this
poor man's life just lost
his his best friend
and heart goes out to the family of all
the people that we
mentioned who passed away um quite a few
people on the
uh in the chat mark are reminding me
that uh we missed the
big big story
of the week so big that it's in variety
this ain't on some questionable
website this comes straight from [ __ ]
variety the industry bible kids
hicks nicks flicks and sticks that kind
of place
alfred molina details doc ock's return
in
spider-man no way home
ooh did you don't say it right i did not
see that story
uh he was trending kevin feige was
trending because
alfred molina apparently didn't get the
memo
shut the [ __ ] up oh yeah that's the new
marvel
you shut the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
and he's out there spilling all the tea
mark as if he's ed brubacher
it's one of those were you gonna make me
come back again i was never doing this
again i'll
say what i want to say he he apparently
doesn't know that you're not supposed to
do this so he gave out some info and i
don't want to necessarily
give it out here in case people are like
you know
hey man i didn't need to know that
because it is spoilery stuff
um but here he says when we were
shooting it
we were all under orders not to talk
about it because it was supposed to be
some
great big secret molina said with a
laugh during an interview with variety
about his role
in the oscar-nominated promising young
woman but you know it's all over the
internet i actually
described myself as the worst kept
secret in hollywood
instead not only did molina confirm his
involvement
in no way home he happily detailed the
experience making the movie
and returning uh to a part he first
played
in his spider-man in 2004.
it was wonderful he said it was very
interesting going back after 17 years to
play the same role
given that in the intervening years i
now have two chins
a waddle crow's feet and a slightly
dodgy lower back when the actor
which i hadn't thought about like this
guy literally played this part almost 20
[ __ ] years ago
and he was no spring chicken then so
it's like come on back it's like well
[ __ ]
but back in the day the the arms were
puppets
nowadays they'll probably be pg so
when the actor asked john watts the
director of no way home
how the movie would bring doc ock back
since as he pointed out i
died well here's the spoiler if you
don't want to know kids turn close your
ears
mute us for the next 30 seconds
and starting now molina said the
director
told him in this universe no one really
dies
now i feel that's like the comic book
universe
i don't think that's very spoilery a lot
of the internet
is poring over that comment going holy
[ __ ] meaning
in that part of the multiverse did he
just confirm the multiverse and i i
don't i think they already confirmed the
multiverse
um but i i don't think that's what he
meant i read it as him going like
you know in this in science fiction
nobody dies exactly that's the way i
took it
um i love that after merlin is like they
told me to be very careful about not
saying very much
meanwhile i'll do a one-man performance
of the entire script who wants to hear
it
uh in their early conversations molina
said that watts told him that the movie
will pick up
doc ock's story from that moment
in the river which in a franchise that
includes multiverses time travel and
diverging timelines
seems plausible enough so that means
that he goes down
holding the [ __ ] globe and they're
taking from that point forward
i guess which means would he be a good
guy
or a bad guy uh probably a bad guy
no he was dying a hero he does sacrifice
himself to pull down the
whatever the [ __ ] that was um
john watts said to him uh did you see
what we did to bob downey jr and sam
jackson
meaning the de-aging process so they'll
be able to take some years off them and
stuff
um uh molina you know said hey man
he said they made robert de niro's face
younger in the irishman
but when he was fighting he looked like
an older guy he looked like an old guy
that's what what what that's worried me
about doing it again
um
he then remembered that the tentacles do
all the work he sat up straight in the
seat he said my basic physical move is
doc ock
as the actor is just this he said and he
declared intensely
at the zoom camera and made a menacing
noise i just do that a lot and the arms
are doing all the killing and smashing
and breaking
i'm just going and then he glared again
what kind of meat with a kind of mean
look on my face it was fantastic
um neither sony pictures nor marvel
studios which are co-producing
spider-man no way home has
even confirmed molina's return
um so now
yes if he's talking about it
that probably means all the other rumors
are true as well
meaning jamie foxx probably definitely
in it
meaning the other two spider-man
probably definitely in it
well you know not necessarily
no his it's it's
one can be true and the others don't
have to be at the same time
i think you know you can say that some
of the other leaks may or may not be
true
they certainly seem like they feel true
um
but all he's really doing is confirming
that he's in it
and until he mentions oh yeah i was on
the set with these nine of the dudes
and i don't give a [ __ ] because i'm 72
years old and what are you gonna do cut
me out of your movie
um which they could um
but yeah i don't know that's all awesome
that all sounds very promising
and i love the fact that they're gonna
de-euthify
five and maybe he becomes a mentor maybe
he becomes the
the uncle ben that that uh this peter
doesn't have anymore
or maybe [ __ ] they're building the
sinister six
it could be um all right what was the
final story avengers campus
the final story is that avengers campus
is uh finally has an opening date
june 4th at california adventure um
you know and disneyland is opening on
april 30th so
hey man there's another section of of
disneyland that we can still not go see
i was just about to say i'm there and i
was like wait i didn't even go to star
wars land yet
really looking forward going to star
wars land then the whole universe shut
down but i do want to go to the avengers
campus
they said what they're adding what the
new rides are um
let's see one area is the world wide
engineering brigade which will center on
spider-man
will feature webb slingers a spider-man
adventure the first
disney ride through attraction
who will be uh and spidey is being
voiced by tom holland
um yeah there's a new uh there's a
guardians of the galaxy well yeah it
opened in 2017 the guardians of the
galaxy themed attraction
there's a doctor strange section that
encounters with a number of marvel
characters roaming the grounds
um sorry yeah
that seems to be i think the spidey
thing is their big
deal they're not specific yet on what dr
strange stuff is and then the guardians
had already been there so i guess they
built around that
well if they need somebody to play a
hero on the ground the dude
dominic from from [ __ ] legend is free
who can i be for you who do you need
that would create so much confusion for
the fan base the like
a dc hero in a marvel exhibit what's
going on
i'm just i'll be sandman all i gotta do
is just grab the voice for a while
here i am or call me christian bale he
did both
there you go um what else we got
is that it that's it that's the news my
friend you wanted news
you nosy [ __ ] that guy
gave you the news martin the internet
news ladies and gentlemen uh jc you
better bam your sweet little ass in here
let me hear it
okay so you can't hear but i think they
hear it on stream
did you guys hear it on stream i don't
even see you
oh it didn't hold on there we go
and you for the one thing you're
supposed to do get out and come back in
go back flush the toilet come back out
okay here we go
here we go everybody quiet count three
one two three
i heard a little like wheeze i heard no
wha you didn't say bamf bro but i'm but
i'm playing the sound effect
out to the stream but i am you know
i can't if i loop it back into zoom
it it does like an eternal loop like
that echo thing that we had that
one night i'll be honest with you i
don't want no sound effect i was digging
you just going bam
with all the enthusiasm like a 42 year
old carpet salesman
back out come back again do it the right
way okay
and take three everybody and action
bamf yeah
yes kiss my friend mwah
ah this is like a workshop episode we're
just figuring it out as we go
let's uh let's get to these questions jc
always picks
the questions so if you don't like the
questions you get to ask blame
blame that [ __ ] guy um the bam for
himself
and they do they do i hear it on twitter
sometimes
it was a dumb [ __ ] question how has
did you really get judged
people are never happy how has the chat
been tonight do you have to throw
anybody out
uh just one guy who i don't think was
i think he was a bot that just came in
shouting about right wing and left wing
stuff
a bot we don't serve their kind
was it was it falcons right wing and
left wing or were they different
wings that was good
i was smart i was politically smart joke
um all right jc what is uh
what's on everybody's mind what is
what can we answer tonight what three
questions can you disappoint the
audience with
the uh the biggest one that i kept
getting from multiple people
uh it first came in and apologies this
is somebody's name in chat
mark bernardin's big black [ __ ] um and
then
followed up wait that's that's the
question that that is the person
asking the question uh
yes then might i suggest which is a
fantastic username that somebody also
has to choose just for equal time
uh kevin smith's tiny white cop
i wonder if that was a fat black patrick
swayze in disguise
[Music]
but jeremy jimmy greer and a number of
other people also wanted to know
um who should the other members of the
seinfeld cast
play in the mcu
so george kramer
jerry and i think we throw newman in for
good measure
george hands down is wolverine
cannot argue guys [ __ ] built of rage
[ __ ] wants to do the job and be like
good night
i'm out of here get the [ __ ] out uh
jerry is a captain america type
i would say kramer
hmm talking about the character right
not the act of the patient
just to be clear just to be clear
keeping it in the seinfeld world
not bringing it into the real world
um all right let me see kramer always
showing up where he's unexpected
i mean he's more like mr mixx plitolic
but like we're
trying to keep it marvel here um
head crawler oh yeah speaking of bounce
i'll take that answer all right um that
covers my do we have to go deeper than
that like newman
and he wanted newman he did want newman
well that was jc's um newman is
easily mo man as far as i'm concerned
um what do you got um well i co-sign um
wolverine
and uh and nightcrawler i feel like
jerry might be mr fantastic
nice um
and uh let's see we already got elaine
who else does that leave i got we got
everybody we got george and elaine
we got jerry's mr fantastic we got um
kramer as nightcrawler newman
as uh mojo
nice good paul but we would have
accepted modok as well
on chat that newman was in the punisher
as we all recall there you go oh maybe
he's kingpin
microchip yeah
[Laughter]
um all right that was good that was good
where did jc go
do and that was on everybody's mind
since
uh um julie louis-dreyfus debuted as
as uh madame hydra who somebody
chastised me in chat to say she's not
necessarily a bad a villain
but let's be honest she will be yeah
same way that pokey's not necessarily a
villain either right but honestly if you
show up with a purple streak in your
hair
at the very least breathy and [ __ ]
talking about who does and doesn't own
the shield
yeah and handing out business cards they
don't have anything on them yeah that's
that's bad guy
she smells like she's in it for her own
interest kids and if you can't figure
that out you're not 50 like me and
that guy almost wants he's not 50 yet
otherwise he wouldn't be able to make
this movie no once that happens
everything evaporates it's like
cinderella cinderfella
the monk bernardin story
oh don't search that on the google's kid
where the [ __ ] is banff boy
uh jeff engelhart in chat said
steinbrenner would be j
jonah jameson oh that's good i thought
that was really good
next uh junice
moisio wanted to know uh stallone has a
small part in guardians of the galaxy
but knowing their fame famous rivalry
from the 80s and 90s
what part would you cast schwarzenegger
in
in the mcu knowing
oh okay based on stallone being in
guardians yeah so stallone is one of
like the og
guardians right that shows up at the end
of the movie
who would you cast who would you cast
schwarzenegger
as keeping in mind their their famous
80s 90s rivalry but also present day
schwarzenegger we're talking about yeah
yes yeah okay
hmm
wow i mean i love when you get a
question that stupefies the entire show
into [ __ ] abject something
that the [ __ ] their feed froze up
because we're both like
huh i mean my
my gut music behind us go ahead sorry my
gut
is and it's tangentially marvel
um only because the comics were marvel
but you know
king conan give me give me like old coin
the barbarian
um which is honestly a thing that i've
been waiting for for 30 years now
and he feels like he's aged into it um
i like that answer i'm gonna go bigger
damn and i'm gonna
i'm gonna go yes sir uh inspect the
banff
graybeard james said old man sabretooth
i
schwarzenegger's short too he's like
five six or five five
don't matter how short he is because i'm
gonna make him big i'm taking arnie
on his galactus
i want to see him in a big funny hat i
want to see him eating planets
i'm here to crush you i'm here to take
you all down
oh and then you get your you got your
stallone
you got yours schwarzenegger and then in
your planet hollywood triumvirate you
get
willis played a silver surfer
oh nice yeah yipika hey [ __ ]
and then you get van damme to play the
beyonder
well now we're just making [ __ ] you
know what's that still explainable
expendables colon the marvel knockoff
marvel cosplay edition um all right
what's
our third question jc uh this one from
just some
pumpkin this is brain burners i'm gonna
need a clove cigarette for this
uh just some punk wanted to know
uh since one division tackled grief
and trauma falcon and the winter soldier
is tackling
race and social political issues what
will loki's commentary be on
having too much of a good time yeah
time is definitely going to be a big
part of it right yeah
it's like regret and responsibility
precious time is
i would have to imagine um
but i say really i say it's probably
going to be about
six to eight episodes long that's what
it's going to be about
we take good question but not a show
ender give us another one jc
um
uh let's see
let's do uh kimberly g85
if you could give the super soldier
serum to any of the golden girls
which one and why
um
well somebody gave it to betty white
clearly
don't waste another shot on her she got
it she's doing fantastic
um let's see
i feel like estelle getty would be the
most fun
yeah um i'm gonna
but but because look i'll be honest with
you i'm not a golden
girls watcher um so i can't go deep into
the mythology of it but out of respect
for
um her being maude and also
[ __ ] closing the bar jc's very bar
our worst christmas special i'd say give
it to bee arthur man
you mark you got a preference you go
deep on golden girls
i do not go deep on golden girls um
and clearly we couldn't give it to
meshach taylor because a black man can't
be captain america
um as we heard as we heard
um no i feel like it's it's it's either
a rue mcclanahan
or a still getty i think you kind of
want the
be immortal super powered um good time
room
or cranky as tall getting i think we
need to
super soldier one more question okay
please
stop or my mom will shoot you full of
super soldiers here
um what fictional characters would
benefit the most
from using the fat man beyond sponsors
what fictional businesses what fictional
characters
so we've got keeps to grow your hair
we've got bluetooth we've got landscaped
who would be the best character to use
each of our sponsors
and we should start with manscape since
they're this week and
being this week's wonderful sponsor fat
man beyond we all know
that uh as mark has pointed out time and
time again
that this the manscape
shaver which comes with a goddamn light
and that buzzy sound um ken is
meant for good enough for your balls but
good enough meant for your balls good
enough for your head
so we know one person in the marvel
universe who has to keep his hair
very specific and that is the great
wolverine himself ladies and gentlemen
so
i would say wolverine benefits big time
the manscaped shaver man from the ball
toner
um from all things manscaped because you
know
you can be called wolverine without
appearing to look like one beyond the
adamantium claws
indeed it's uh it's a [ __ ] tagline
we're workshopping mark
we haven't landed on it exactly we you
know it's in that neighborhood anyway
over to you
um i i feel like for manscaped i go lobo
i feel like lobo could use a little
taming of that mane
i mean you can be wild in almost every
way mr lobo
you don't need to be wild down there
um for previous sponsors of the show as
in keeps who is not a sponsor this week
but we still love them just the same
professor x for sure lex luthor for sure
yeah i'm trying to think if there are
any heroes with like
a male pattern but oh um norman osborne
like that's a dude who you can tell is
losing his hair
like he had an excellent point the d
weirdos
luthor and and uh who's the other one i
said professor x
they they're two they they lost their
chance at keeps
but norman osborne who's thinning gets a
chance to keep
that's well thought of mark excellent
point thank you
thank you that's why that's why lex
luthor is so bitter
he missed out on keeps he did he
couldn't he could have kept his hair
alas um well done [ __ ] they don't even
sponsor him this week you gotta
hold luchu luchu
look nobody needs to get laid more than
batman
so give him a [ __ ] give him a thermos
full of blue chew
give him a night off for heaven's sakes
and this dude's in
peak physical condition let him
bust a nut
i wonder if mr fantastic has the
opposite problem like he's very stretchy
and bendy
but does he have a rigid problem
a rigidity issue that's one point he's
like look
what good how big if it can stretch big
deal if it's not doing the job
yeah stretching is easy rubber bandy is
easy
but you know if i got a standard
attention i might need a little chew on
my side
and he likes it because it could be
right on him and people don't see it
because his outfit's blue so he's just
like
yeah he just landed on his
[Laughter]
two good ones death star kitty said uh
hank pym
because he just got his wife back after
50 years
ah that's good and uh something tells me
that he does not have a problem keeping
it up if he hasn't had his wife around
for 50 years
uh and then the other would be deadpool
because he seems like he's always
he's always going at it he seems to need
no help though that dude's just like
[ __ ]
he's uh he's clearly got you know uh
what do they call that [ __ ] and you [ __ ]
too much
joy like
we're all stumped because we're like is
there such a thing
is that an affliction that i missed
[ __ ] too much what are you mad
yeah i i i'm gonna stand by my batman
answer man because think about it
even if you forced him to take the night
off even if alfred was like i hid the
keys you can't even get in the [ __ ]
batcave tonight
you're just hanging out you're [ __ ]
watching tv or whatever
even or even if he was like i i hired a
hooker
which turned out to be selena kyle in a
weird you know [ __ ] coincidence
uh because she used to be a prostitute
in the comics kids um
even if all that transpires you know
that dude is thinking about his war on
crime
you can't get hard thinking about a war
on crime
you just think about the war on crime so
at least with blue chew
little head tells the big head you think
about the war in crime i'm gonna think
about
yeah you're gonna i'm allie thank you
you could do we could do like a uh
a call back to the seinfeld
and shrinkage and maybe it's uh aquaman
it's always cold very nice i like that
as well
um there are some people that pointed
out yelled rather in chat mark that
batman is married
in current comics continuity which
i you know i acknowledge that for some
my batman's not married it's too happy
for batman
oh come on come on um in any event
um what other sponsors have we had bam
boy
native deodorant native ceo
point nativedeo.com who would benefit
from that
the blob
you know what i'm saying like you know
the appearance is not withstanding
there's no reason to smell
and with native deo you don't have to
worry about that
no i i think the rhino could also use
some of that native deo
because i'm pretty sure he's
hermetically sealed into that [ __ ]
suit and the odor inside there has got
to be serious
you know who'd sign off on a heartbeat
pamela eisley dr pamela eisley aka
poison because it's all plant-based
or she might be mad yes like what how
dare you
kill my plants for your smelling good
nature you're right man you're right you
look let's we know who'd [ __ ] use it
and needs it
because he's on a never-ending war on
crime even the nights that alfred makes
him sit home and
tries to hire a prostitute uh batman
because man he's always [ __ ] at it so
i bet he keeps
he keeps one of them tiny little native
deodorants that you could get at the
dwayne reed in
his utility pouch so that periodically
he could be like
put it back in because that suit really
seals in the flavor
yeah you know um what other sponsors
have we had
um i don't know that's good enough
you missed out on the uh on the
perfect one stinkore
for native deo that was
uh from i didn't know this was the part
of the show where we take
notes they see
any other ways we can perhaps improve
the show for you jay-z the swamp
thing a lot of people in chat talking
about swamp thing smelling bad
i think that's like being uh you know
[ __ ]
presumptuous i don't think he smells bad
i think he smells like nature
like look you can [ __ ] put up with
the smell of patchouli
you could put up with the smell of swamp
thing man and maybe he smells like
[ __ ] daisies he could smell like all
the flowers
he can that's true he can grow flowers
out his ass but the thought
toxic avenger maybe oh good call not
strictly a comic book character has been
in a comic but not anyone i would ever
think of as a comic book character
um more of a superhero and questionable
at that
fair but yeah but you're absolutely
right there's a guy that could probably
use some native
um that was good man it was good times
fine we got a lot accomplished talk
about
falcon and the winter soldier we talked
to christian
we talked about the uh
my nft's drop james alan bob crypto
studio you throw that
link uh up in the chat somewhere jc
there it is we got it on screen now yeah
look at that um
the uh you know we we talked to
christian and then we [ __ ] heard all
the news from mark
and uh we answered like six questions
and then we answered yeah like [ __ ]
this is
so much value for your money on fat man
beyond
you're paying how much for this [ __ ]
and still we just keep breaking it off
what time is it 7
15. what time we start 4 15. yeah we've
been
about every it's like a three-hour
[ __ ] show
thank god we're not on tv because they'd
be like get off
you can't just like we have to do the
news the actual
he's like we got other [ __ ] [ __ ]
um we thank you for tuning in and
hanging out with us here
on a fine saturday afternoon evening
what have you and whatnot
uh we haven't got no show without jc
putting us out there
to the world jc the proprietor of the
scum and villainy cantina which is now
open correct jc
open wednesday through sunday 6 p.m on
go get your drink on man and the [ __ ]
most cosmic
geekiest bar on the [ __ ] planet one
you'll never get in a fight at
particularly now
plus quarantine i bet you no bar fights
now man
people are just like so happy to see you
hi human yeah and everybody's got to be
seated so they don't
there's no wandering everybody's just
seated and hanging out that's how the
fights begin when they start wandering
right
well you've got to be eight feet away
from everybody so like
unless you are reed richards you're not
going to hit anybody
man that's true best time in the world
to go to a bar
if you're one of those people like me
who's like i don't want to get in a bar
fight i just assume
bar fights break out all the time and
that's predicated on having seen a lot
of movies and tv shows about
bars you know roadhouse i expect every
bar to be like roadhouse
yes probably isn't but it definitely is
not at [ __ ] jc's place i'll tell you
that much
uh there would be no show ladies and
gentlemen without the guy giving you all
the information
uh give it up for mr mark
bernard thank you sir always a pleasure
um and we'll be back next week of course
um with some more with the final recap
of
falcon and the winter soldier yes um
until then ladies and gentlemen that is
fat man beyond for this week i'm kevin
smith
i am mark bernard tune in next time same
fat time same fat channel smodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
by the power of grayskull
you